[Laughter]
what's that now hey what's up
we're tearing the goddamn furniture up i
know it well throwing mouth don't throw
it don't throw it well she could throw
the ball yeah
she's going
to get it get it didn't you do it
[ __ ] cats hilarious solaires
[ __ ] up and i'm drinking this this is a
[ __ ] fantastic um yeah because he
just right before we came on he was like
ooh this is a good sunrise and i was
like yeah if you do say yourself
was that that
that was
that's my i'm sorry it's in my dna smart
answer isn't my dad i can't help it i
can't
you know even if i don't say it out loud
i'm thinking it is that sam's club
silver tequila yeah it's just as good as
malaga silver this exactly i think it's
it's probably the same [ __ ] i mean you
know it's good i had to get well i still
have some sam's vodka leftover but i had
to get skye today because i'm not
driving all the way to [ __ ] sam's
yeah
but you know we have a liquor so we have
a liquor store right up the street yeah
and sky is 26. was it 26 i think it was
25.99 for the big ass bottle
it's way cheaper at sam's but sam's is
like really far so yeah sam's you can
get that same size bottle and it tastes
just like gray goose and it's like 11
bucks
i think it's 13.99 it used to be 11.
yeah plus it went up a little bit it did
go up a little bit last time i bought it
at sam's it was 13.99 which is still
like half price half the price of sky
and it's just as good yeah but like i
said i'm not driving all the way to
[ __ ] sam's just to get vodka yeah it
looks like everybody's showing up
kanavasalan is in
he goes so good northman was good huh
and he says that a good i had a good
taste yes we're gonna talk i thought it
was [ __ ] great we're gonna talk about
northman today but we're also good but
not a whole lot we'll do a review of it
we're gonna do reviews on sunday like
for the matinee yeah because yeah we saw
it uh last night actually
because i was like we better see it
because it's only like in one theater
yeah so it might not hang around but
yeah i think it's almost like uh [ __ ]
too bad i didn't see it when it first
came out like i wouldn't mind seeing
that in uh i wish i would have seen it
in dolby you could have seen it in dolby
because uh so i'm gonna have to go get
the some kind of special edition blu-ray
i want badass packaging on it
okay this
this movie okay
this was like exactly tom's kind of yes
[Laughter]
it is homage and conan
it it knows it's homage and conan
certain
the story kind of happens sometimes in
the same order but it's a different
story
um
it directly um homages a few scenes from
conan
i want to spoil anything okay um it's
definitely
being john milius as a [ __ ] it's
a lot more
i know amelia's loves this movie
okay
this is like some [ __ ] milius would just
[ __ ] love yeah this seems like some
[ __ ] he would write
it's the tone is not the same as conan
conan was kind of epic and in a certain
way positive with a bunch of bunch of
epic [ __ ] like nietzsche and [ __ ]
philosophy going on in it with uh
wagnerian style [ __ ] music this tone
is very different okay
it's just as epic
the soundtrack is [ __ ]
norse tribal so it's a bunch of chanting
and a bunch of [ __ ] drums i think
there is some classical stuff in it but
really it's mostly damn chanting
uh the
the tone is [ __ ] satanic
because it's pretty badass yeah the tone
is satanic because
the religion and everything that they're
doing is like straight out of [ __ ]
all the folk horror
like midsummer and wickerman and a
[ __ ] uh heredity like that
they're doing some wild [ __ ]
and it's all accurate to what the norse
used to do with human sacrifices and
[ __ ] punishments and their
their culture it's all in there all
right and
and [ __ ] they've got um berserker
cults
where
dudes going beez arc where they become
animalistic take drugs and just make
themselves suffered so they could just
become as bad as a [ __ ] and then
they would hire themselves out as kind
of like mercenaries to help
tribal kings [ __ ] conquer other
tribes and then it actually accurately
shows what they did
including like burning little children
up alive and [ __ ] [ __ ] in front of
the parents and just
nasty nasty [ __ ]
got an all-star cast in it bjork is in
it she plays a [ __ ] satanic [ __ ]
witch yeah she's on one team yeah
they're not satanic they didn't have a
concept of satan it's just that you know
norse religion had a lot of [ __ ] dark
[ __ ] in it and
um
that's in there uh you had [ __ ]
uh oh wes's name dude that played the uh
dude that was in platoon and and played
in he was in the lighthouse who william
defoe william defoe is in it he plays a
[ __ ] shaman he's just another wicked
[ __ ] uh he's cool though
um
it's just there's a lot of good
everybody kind of looks the part
tom cruise's ex-wife's in it she plays
the queen nicole kid nicole kidman i
think she deserves better than being
called tom cruises tom cruise yeah i
always forget her name she has her cool
she has a very uh distinguished career
yeah yeah
nicole
yeah and she looks great she looks great
in this movie she's
might be a little bit older than me but
she's like a real good real good shape
she plays the [ __ ] queen
a norse queen
and then they got um
all kinds of stuff happens you know
and uh who's the dude
what what's the main character's name do
they even really mention his name yeah
but i can't pronounce it yeah you might
write down the dude's name he's just
hell bent they do say it like they just
say it a bunch of times but i can't
pronounce it right correctly so i'm not
even gonna attempt it and um
they show
like that norse tree of life and how
that [ __ ] works uh valkyrie
uh ghosts
um
demonic things
[ __ ] wolves
[ __ ] um odin's [ __ ] ravens and
odin's wolves are in it and i don't
think they ever showed odin they showed
a lot of they did kind of briefly but he
was just kind of yeah i guess yeah
that's right they did show him briefly
he does show it's just it's just a good
story
and it's um there's not an ounce of soy
in this [ __ ] none zero and it's
a great director and dude who did
lighthouse he might now send the witch
and the witch yeah and this also has uh
what's-her-face anna taylor joy i think
her name is that was in the witch she's
in this too yeah like as a major she has
a major role in it so it's it's like
action adventure and horror
and kind of like um
historic kind of historically accurate
pretty much i mean there are certain
things
about the norse that are not really
discussed but to discuss that kind of
[ __ ] it would have
kind of taken away from the badassery of
the movie you know i think
because
people think all all
all the norse were vikings you know what
i mean it kind of the stereotype the
vikings were just raiders
they had a short growing season
so they were always lacking food
if the population would
rose which it was that at that time in
that area because they were pretty
successful they couldn't feed everybody
so they'd have to go in raiding parties
to go get [ __ ] from europe
and they brought back people as slaves
because who's gonna who's gonna turn
down beautiful women so they just bring
them back well that that exacerbates the
population problem so the more people
they brought back the more rating they
had to do
it's a it's a vicious thing it's like a
vicious cycle
but the average norse
norse person was not a viking they were
just
farmers you know civilians you know the
but the
the vikings weren't civilians they were
they were basically mercenaries kind of
like pirates you know not every european
was a pirate but europe had pirates it
was like that
um even though
i guess it was kind of becoming part of
their culture as they were growing that
you couldn't grow enough food to feed
the place and you also had they knew
about gold and they had trading routes
and stuff that they were trying to
exploit
so you just had to steal it you know
stealing it from weaker people and which
is like part of the viking rules you
know
and their religion
it's like hey using this can i have your
lunch money
they take it like
it was survival of the fittest you know
what i mean you can't defend this [ __ ]
so it's ours
you know he couldn't stop us from taking
it so we were it's a blog to us tila
says prince amleth was his name that's
yeah i knew it started with a i just
couldn't remember like how they
pronounced it they did say it a bunch i
think his last name was beywolf or or
something too something that kind of
sounded sounds like i remember like anna
taylor she was named like olga yeah
that's like pretty easy to remember yeah
love that period scene by the way i'm
not going to get to it because hugo is
like i'll be back in half an hour so i
don't want to hear any spoilers so
what did you think of it tayla
she says the cinematography in this yeah
she said it's a good movie and she says
the cinematography in this movie was on
point i think i prefer edgar's the witch
the best yeah i mean i like all of his
movies because i like that he does all
different things
and i kind of feel like like i said
particularly with the witch in
particular with this one it seems like
he's really into recreating the [ __ ]
like as realistically as possible you
know like in the witch he actually used
like a lot of actual
old english or a lot of um you know [ __ ]
like that was written from that time
period like for the dialogue
and you know he even had people like
hand make the costumes like exactly how
they would have made them back then and
stuff like that so i kind of feel like
he did he's very into
accuracy like period accuracy i liked it
i thought it was like the viking
equivalent of say like apocalypto that
movement apocalypto that was good too
all right yeah so connor you i know khan
likes apocalypto as well yeah that's a
good one you'd like this
i mean this is back when they made real
white boys
the thing about this movie is that it's
long as [ __ ] it's like two and a half
hours long but it didn't it didn't seem
like it it goes fast because i was
sitting there thinking oh it's like i
should get like a big uh drink like a
big soda because i get really thirsty
like if i have to go more than like 15
minutes without water
but i got so wrapped up in the movie
that it's like i forgot like i didn't
even go get a drink and then yeah so i
was all right
even though i think it's 2 hours and 17
minutes casting was spot on
everybody doing this [ __ ] looks like
they could actually do it they're in
good shape they [ __ ] rough looking
[ __ ] people with noses missing
and
guys in good shape guys in bad shape
[ __ ]
it's just
everything looks like it could it could
happen
yeah it's good
it was i liked it yeah i liked it very
much yeah
yeah we just had a whole uh
yeah it was fun yesterday because we
were like well we wanted to go to the
movie and they it was only one showing
and it wasn't dolby yeah uh because i
didn't realize that doctor strange like
the new doctor strange movie started
last night so it's like the [ __ ]
theater was packed there was a million
people and like people with costumes and
little kids running around everywhere
but um yeah so they only had one showing
of
the north men and it was at 6 25
so
we actually ended up going to
the altmo mall like across from the
theater like a few hours before that
like to get someone to eat and i got i
actually got to like wander around in
barnes noble which is one of my favorite
things to do so i bought like some books
to review
got this shirt
in fye i got this one and i got they had
a sale where they were like hey if you
buy one shirt you get another one half
off so i was like well [ __ ] me i'm gonna
go get another one then so i got this
creep show one and i got a hellraiser
one too they have like some cool
uh shirts in there so
zach's asking how her her acting was for
bjork's act it was good real good yeah
she's only in one she's only one scene
yeah i didn't know it was her she looks
cool as [ __ ] though she plays a witch
yeah she does look cool [ __ ] yeah but
it's just one scene so it's just kind of
like she's not yet i didn't even know it
was her uh yeah uh and tc we need to
keep going because more good stuff's
coming yeah we saw some good trailers
[ __ ] nope looked good
that was the new jordan peel movie and
it's like
i had heard about it and yeah so it's
like so it's aliens it looks like aliens
i guess aliens and horrors it's like a
horror alien boob and i was like man
that looks pretty cool and then when the
title of it came up it's just called
nope nope
and i just like laughed out loud i'm
like oh my god this is
the best horror movie title ever the new
trailer for uh top gun looked good
yeah that starts in a couple weeks i
think that starts may 27th through the
same we'll see
uh there was another there was a couple
other ones that looked real good they
were coming that new baz lerman elvis
movie i think i kind of want to see that
yeah i like baslerman i love moulin
rouge and
did he make that roman juliet movie that
you love so much i think so i think that
might be this that might be basilar too
but i i mean i love mulan rage if y'all
haven't seen that old romeo and juliet
with [ __ ] uh
uh oh leonardo dicaprio and what's her
face claire david claire danny that
girl's so cute man and she's coming out
with claire dave's has a new movie out
she's still cute
i'm gonna beat her in a long time she's
gonna be pushing 50 now yeah and she's
still look she still looks just like
that
um no that movie's great it's got a
great soundtrack
and it was all
modern music for the time of the 90s
and uh it's like it's taking place in a
parallel universe a parallel
1990s somewhere in central america
between like cartels like a french
cartel and a damn
spanish cartel somewhere you know in
venezuela or something which is kind of
what level
you know [ __ ] italy was at that time
that those like i believe i think verona
was in italy wasn't it
it was one of the italian states i think
um
but it's like uh
yeah that's a great movie
and um
i went and checked
if
the humor actually
if it was it being misrepresented were
they really making drug references were
they really making sexual innuendo
references oh absolutely yes they were
absolutely and there was all that
references to possible homosexuality in
there
the mercurio was that was his name
mercurio
he was played by the black guy who was
in drag half the time yeah isn't that
that character's name i think that's
what his mercutio
was it's been a long time yeah i thought
maybe it was like man you know are are
they portraying that character correctly
it has and yeah it is it was
for centuries
people reading in between the line is
that
his his bodyguard and friend [ __ ]
mercurio with his name was
seems to be in love with [ __ ]
um romeo
because he says a bunch of sideways
stuff that could be interpreted to that
that's why he dies for him but then he
curses both houses and [ __ ] well it
could never happen i kind of feel like
what is in there what a lot of people
don't realize and we kind of went into
this a little bit like when i was in
high school people didn't change because
we read um no what i was going to say
was that we read a lot of shakespeare in
high school
um and
shakespeare's [ __ ] it's smutty yeah i
mean it's it's muddy but it's like
people don't realize it because the
language is archaic and you don't
exactly know what he's referring to yeah
one of my favorite things that i bought
when i was in st augustine uh on
vacation
i went in like one of the mediums there
and it's just it's just right over there
but i bought like this big coffee mug
and it's all covered with shakespearean
insults it's pretty rad
well shakespeare wasn't for the the
high-minded even though it was
high-minded it was for the rabble yeah
it was just for regular people yeah
people think of it now as some like
lofty kind of it absolutely wasn't it
was for the common people for the common
people but um it had the subtexts in it
were all
very deep you know what i mean if i can
whoever was writing those and i'm not
sure it was the same person who wrote
them all there might have been fake
shakes we still haven't done a show i
need to write that down we need to know
a show about that a lot of mysteries
about that whether that was one author
doing that well yeah i don't think it
was a teacher and some people think it
was that uh christopher marlar or
whatever yeah
i know i got to fix it but i didn't even
touch it i don't know why it like
[ __ ] did that ghosts
but there's a lot of subtext in there
that
only a genius would have come up with
and uh you can you can
watch those plays and look at them at a
superficial level but then there's a
bunch of subtext
because there was [ __ ] they couldn't say
back then yeah and uh so only the only
higher iq people could get
what the message was because half the
time it was down political and uh you
couldn't make a lot of political
commentary back then and not get your
head cut off
so a lot of the [ __ ] that they did was
deniable you could say oh that's not in
there that's your imagination i didn't
say that i didn't the place like that
might be you you're a dirty man
that's not what it says yeah i didn't
say that but that's exactly what it was
there's a lot of references to drugs
lots of references to fooling around on
your wife well that was that that's
obvious and a lot there's references to
homosexuality in there in the subtext
that you know talking about loves that
could never happen and weird [ __ ] like
that that's what they're talking about
and um
uh
drugs
they don't know what drug they're
talking about but it's definitely drugs
that they keep talking about they're
they had [ __ ] together i mean humans
have been doing drugs since humans
existed
uh yes it would make you see fairies and
take you into other
other worlds and
[ __ ] something
even the romans had stuff like that but
we don't know what they we know the
names of the drug we don't know what it
refers to yeah lsd or
opium or that nobody knows
john smith says people often forget that
shakespeare is packed with dick and fart
jokes yeah it absolutely is yep and tila
brought up the movie men looks good i
love my a24 films i was going to bring
that up actually because we saw that uh
trailer as well that's that chick that
was just in uh i'm thinking of ending
things yeah and uh that looks really
weird that looks like right up my alley
and the black phone that's when i we
were talking about this on the car on
the way home i said last time we went to
the movies like months and months ago
and because we were talking about ethan
hawk because ethan hawk had a had a
short uh had a small role in the
northmen and i was like oh that was
ethan hawk and tom didn't recognize him
but i was like oh ethan hawk was also in
that supposed i think that's like a
blumhouse movie right like the black
phone and i kept seeing the trailer for
it i was like oh that looks pretty good
but then
i don't i haven't heard anything about
it so like did it never never come out
because i kind of feel like i kept
seeing the trailers like months and
months ago and i thought it must be out
by now
i remember seeing the black phone for
like i thought it was supposed to come
out in like [ __ ] december or january
or something she likes you shirt
thank you yeah
they're asking me if i'm gonna dress up
as the saxophone man no i'm not gonna
dress up a saxophone man
um
new jurassic park movie yeah we saw that
our
i was told the last one wasn't that good
but you know i haven't really seen
anything i've only seen the first one
yeah i'm not gonna lie yeah
if i yeah she is teased mentioning fire
starter that looks good
i saw that i saw that
i saw that trailer on youtube and i was
like oh yeah i got to see that as long
as they do the book justice that was a
great book
that's a great book
yeah i haven't seen the uh
i haven't seen the trailer he also says
and they're they're remaking salem's lot
that'll be good if they do it right
yeah i wouldn't mind that because
honestly they haven't done like a film i
mean the one they did before is like a
tv mini series yeah and i like that one
i mean that one's fantastic but i
wouldn't mind seeing it done as like a
movie movie also says the remake and
exorcist
well see i don't why why
that seems like why because they've
already made
prequels and that kind of stuff i just
kind of feel like there's not really a
lot of places you can go with that and
it's just so
i mean the original is so iconic it just
seems like why i didn't even realize
this but do you know that they remade
the movie of rosemary's baby no didn't
they remade that i didn't know that
either until i was like scrolling
through like 2b or something the other
day and i was like wait what i'm like
who the [ __ ] baby who the [ __ ] that
and yeah i was just like when did that
happen well that's what they're gonna do
next right they're gonna remake star
wars the originals
watch them do that they'll [ __ ] that up
too
well you know when you have classic [ __ ]
like that don't remake it
yeah i'm not i'm not against remakes in
gen well you know it's never usually my
thing but it's like i
i'm not against it in principle
especially if the movie like they didn't
really do it right the first time or
you know it was an adaptation of a book
but it wasn't that close or something
like that like if there's something else
you could bring to it then i don't have
a problem with it but if you're taking
something that's like culturally iconic
like the exorcist and trying to remake
that i don't really know what you're
hoping
yeah i don't really know what you're
hoping to accomplish although you know
sometimes i could be proved wrong
because i remember
before the suspiria remake came out
um i was like why the [ __ ] would they
ever remake suspiria because if you do
it just like dario argento did it then
it's pointless and if you do it
completely different then it's not
superior anymore because that movie was
like so wrapped up in the visual style
which is very distinctive to him
but
i have to say he they did um that luca
whatever his last name starts with the g
uh that remade it he did go in a
completely different direction but it
was still kind of like the spirit of the
movie and he kind of went in opposite
like visual direction i was like okay
i like that i like what you did there so
i'll take back that like they shouldn't
have remade that it's not the same it's
almost kind of like not even a remake
it's almost like a different movie in
the same not even the same universe i
don't know it's just like a different
take on it which i thought was kind of
cool if you're gonna do a remake do
something like that i thought it was too
long
yeah
boring it had a real good ending
ooh um
but maybe i had to see it again i just i
sat in the theater and i was getting
tired of it
although you liked it at the time you
said i liked it at the time but it was
going on too long i i think i would have
edited it down some
but yeah i don't know i have to see it
again it's not some of some of that [ __ ]
you got to see it a couple of times yeah
especially that one because that one had
so much stuff yeah that was like
subtextual and a lot of stuff that was
going on kind of that you really had to
like pay attention to that you'd
probably only catch on a re re-watch
oh she likes that fire stars or books
yeah that was one of one of his better
books there was a time in which [ __ ]
all of stephen king's books were really
good
but after tommy knockers came out it's i
noticed it started to suffer i didn't
think thomas well after his car accident
was when it really started although i
can't really say because i haven't read
a lot of his newer stuff and some of the
newer stuff i remember not too long ago
i reviewed on my channel on my little
channel or my show
um one of his newer books which was
revival it's not that new i think it's
2014 or 2016 or something like that and
i just kind of i didn't even know he
wrote that and i randomly came across an
used bookstore and that was actually
pretty great like it reminded me of it
was very like ray bradbury
esque and um yeah i was really into it
so i can't really say like oh all this
new stuff is bad because i haven't read
enough of it to like make that a
assessment you know what i'm saying
somebody was saying they're remaking
terminator where's this
oh man why would they do that that's
what i'm saying that's one that it's
like why bother yeah they [ __ ]
terminator up so badly there should
never be any more terminator that that's
a wrap on terminator they just [ __ ] it
up too much too many bad terminator
movies
and
what made terminators so good is that it
was a very well executed executed b
movie
and arnold schwarzenegger was the bad
guy
and in the in that day and time
in the 80s when that thing came out
seen it for the first time it was
mind-blowing
skynet
wow that what a concept
[Laughter]
the internet there was no such thing you
know what i mean [ __ ] they could
become alive
and then it it sends a robot from the
future back to our time and it it's the
cyborg it's flash on the outside
man that was just a [ __ ]
novel idea
they didn't invent the idea that
actually it was supposed to be a ripoff
of a movie called the exterminator which
i've never seen
uh which is supposed to be a really bad
p movie called the exterminator i'd like
to see it though now that i remembered
it
um
but it's just
that
that could only happen once it was a
movie in its place in time you can't do
that now
it's not as impressive as it was just
leave the original a [ __ ] loan
it's like remaking [ __ ] wizard of oz
or something which they have done but
it's best as musicals and you know which
is like well they did the whiz
yes they're saying it's a musical yeah
you know
um but that was like a different take on
it and made it like more like a musical
which like i said that's fine and they
did like in more recent years they did
what was that thing called was it called
wicked and that was actually not the
wizard of oz but it was kind of like
the [ __ ] from like the witch's point of
view you know what i mean so that was
like a big success like on broadway and
stuff
uh so there was that yeah tila said uh
zoe saldana played in the remake of
rosemary's baby it was okay
not good not really bad too much cgi
original is a masterpiece yeah i just
didn't even know that they remade it uh
john smith said i thought the suspiria
remake was pretty decent i did too it's
a very arty movie so if you're not into
that then you probably wouldn't like it
but it's completely different than the
original that's why the the the trailer
to men didn't really impress me that
much because it felt like it was trying
to be real art already
but it's 824 that's kind of what they're
known for
i thought it looked cool like i thought
it looked super creepy like all those
guys like being the same guy except like
in different guys
looking trailers can be deceptive
sometimes the tread the way the trigger
yeah it's hard to say right like uh and
then tila also says they're making a
film of judy blooms are you their god
it's me margaret
i said you know what i'm surprised that
has that ever been made into a film
before because judy bloom's stuff
was so [ __ ] massive like in the 80s
i'm actually kind of amazed that they
didn't really
i don't really remember any major film
adaptations of any of her books even
though every single girl i knew read
them everybody
that one i think somebody gave me that
like for my 11th birthday or some [ __ ]
was like well your family members your
like your mom or your grandma or
something like that like if you grew up
back in the 80s if you're a girl
um
they would always give you that book in
particular because it talks about
periods so i guess they're kind of like
that's not the only thing that it talks
about but it just talks about like
growing up as a girl you know what i
mean so a lot of uh parents and
grandparents would give their girls that
book so they could kind of like deal
with their [ __ ] you know it's like
what's it like with your boobs growing
and [ __ ] like that but um the thing that
cracks me up is i first read that book
and this i don't know if it's been
updated since then
but when i first read that book
i don't know if you know i think it was
originally written in the 50s i want to
say 50s or maybe early 60s i can't
remember when it was first written
but back then
forgive me guys but um
back then like they didn't have you know
they have like the maxi pads that were
like sticky on the bottom that would
like to like stick in your underwear or
whatever back then you had to buy like a
belt that had hooks on it
that you like put under your clothes and
like put like a towel in there
so it's like they didn't have
you know the high-tech [ __ ] they have
like maxi pads with wings and all that
kind of [ __ ] like nowadays
and so i'm reading this going what the
[ __ ] because like even then like even
though when i was a kid like i knew what
[ __ ] you know maxi pads were but i
was like bel what are you talking about
but i've heard that they've like updated
it to more reflect because otherwise
doubt kids nowadays will really be
reading it man what the [ __ ] what is
this
i don't know what that is is that is
that old or is that new that's old yeah
i've been i've been trying to like uh
you know get through the yeah okay so
thank you zach
the way the original exorcist was shot
has influenced cinematography overall to
this day so it already looks like a
modern movie so what's the point yeah it
does pretty much yeah thanks for the
super chat zach yeah thank you very much
we did that whole show on last wednesday
and didn't get a single super chat
that's right we didn't we got a single
soup chat that well
it happens sometimes
what's up poop it happens sometimes yeah
i never [ __ ] plug anything and i
never ask and never even try to sell any
cookbooks i never haven't even tried to
sell any shirts lately
i know what's your fault the thing is
though the thing is though is that uh we
didn't get the uh the designs printed
out yet
yeah i have they're done and i just
haven't i just haven't got the
we just haven't got screens you got to
send them to what you call it and i'll
go down there and pick them up yeah i
got a canon one and i got the ocb ocp
communications
it's the old printing place that's the
closest one
i guess i can take the bike down there
and pick it up
that's the thing i usually go to fedex
office
but some places don't print on the
transparency because you know sometimes
i've sent it there like online and then
they call and be like we don't have any
transparency to print this on so you
have to like drive all over [ __ ] town
to figure out where they have
transparencies the pain in the ass
um teila says there are so many books
that deserve a movie yeah i agree
they're so lazy in hollywood always
looking to cash in yeah and it's like
there's a lot of movies that are made
that are actually based on books that i
didn't realize were based on books so
there is that but
i mean i read i've been reading a lot of
horror fiction and
man i've read some stuff like lately
that i was just kind of like man why
don't they make this into a movie i got
a feeling i got a feeling those uh those
days are coming to an end with hollywood
just making random movies like a factory
because uh nobody's going to see them
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] unless they're
any good
so i think there's going to be fewer
movies higher quality which means i
think a lot of hollywood's going to
vanish because they they were
overstaffed i believe
probably just going to be [ __ ] like
you got an emc theater
i guess they can work directly with
studios right because you have all those
[ __ ] uh independent studios like a24
yeah you know what i mean their shit's
actually pretty good i like a24 stuff
it's good
yeah you should you know what you'd
probably like saint maude i i watched it
and did a review of it like on my own
but you probably like it too it's pretty
[ __ ] up somebody was saying that uh
there was a an outer limits or something
that was kind of like uh
terminator
maybe i think i think terminator they
said that it was a copy of something
called the exterminator
um
but i've never seen that movie
to me the terminator mostly reminded me
of uh yule brenner's gunfighter
character out of westworld yeah because
there's a lot of a lot of the terminator
in that
showing what he could how he saw things
and
confusing his infrared vision and
everything and
he was your brenner was the original
terminator
holy parish of doom says is talking
about dance macabre the stephen king
book honestly that's one of my favorite
stephen king books it's non-fiction in
case you guys didn't know um i've read
it over and over and over again i've
read it so many times that my paperback
like fell apart like you could pick it
up now like the cover falls off and all
the pages fall out so like that's i've
read it so many times
uh and also they said harlan ellison
sued uh cameron over terminator and won
yeah that's right because wasn't it
based on or was really similar to
um harlan ellison story or like a
concept
i can't remember what it was though
i got really really behind
uh everyone loved the evil dead remake i
found it so so i don't you know what i
didn't even like i heard it was good too
but i just never got around to watching
it because i was like i'm too busy
watching the original
and i'm too busy like watching other
horror movies that aren't remakes of
things
there's like tons of them so both
disparities are great yeah we'll go see
men i just honestly that looked really
creepy to me
um yeah mango said i saw wicked last
week what a great show yeah i've heard
really good things about that i've also
read the book yeah i still need to read
the book too
uh tila says hereditary still stands my
favorite a24 film mine too uh but
midsummer is also good
and dude
yeah tila said all ages and races of
girls know about judy bloom honestly
um i think i read like most of her books
i've read are you there god it's me
margaret like lost in lots of times um i
also liked uh what was that one
uh
starring sally j friedman as herself
that was also good there was one called
deeney that was like for older
girls
um
but the well the thing about judy bloom
is that she really found like a good
niche in
books that were geared toward
why a like a young adult like a preteen
market girls
but tackling
like serious issues
like you know growing up like periods
and stuff but also like eating disorders
you know sexual abuse that type of stuff
in a way that was like really relatable
so i kind of feel like i mean she made
like a whole [ __ ] i don't think she's
still alive is she
judy bloom
but um yeah she's like a really famous
uh author like why a author she wrote
some adult books too
but um
i'm just surprised that they hadn't done
more of her
they haven't adapted any of her stuff
really
i mean because her stuff was like so
popular especially back in the 80s i
feel like everybody read that [ __ ]
everybody if you're a girl i mean like
every girl read that [ __ ]
um i'm trying to think of like some
other stuff
because i was reading one of my old blog
posts the other day about books that i
really liked when i was growing up
that i always like wanted them to make
movies out of and they never did
finally they made one out of um
you know the house of the clock in its
walls which probably like my favorite
book when i was you know a kid like a
preteen
and they finally made a movie of that
which was pretty good but i always
wondered why they didn't make one of any
of ellen raskin's stuff like the westing
game like the westing game
is one of my favorite
that's probably my second favorite like
book from when i was a kid and i'm i
think that would make it like an amazing
amazing movie i don't know why they
don't do it but maybe somebody will one
of these days
because i feel like it's still
it's still in print and i feel like
people still read it it won like the
newbery medal and all that
bob um says any fantasy or historical
story done right the first time should
not be remade it's not they have to it's
not like they have to update technology
or anything yeah
um let's see
i still haven't seen x i gotta see that
i think it's up for streaming now but i
think it's still a little bit too
expensive
okay gram thurs comes in and it's asking
some questions i'm a little bit behind
so sorry
um gramps are just asking some questions
like like he does rando fun number one
is meg at the oasis agoth or just a hot
biker chick
two name one famous writer you would
like to hang with for an evening
three secrets to making a shitload of
money on youtube
you must be talking about meg spivey
yeah oasis there's only one meg i know
the oasis she talked about that girl i
took the video of her she's showing the
bike that's probably what he's talking
about
meg is um
no megas and goth mega is a biker chick
that and what they are around here is uh
and she's kind of
unusual for a biker chick because she's
she's a biker
dj she's a dj okay
um
in this area
what bikers are around here is their
country people they they either live on
these farms they live in between farms
some of them grow up working on farms or
living next to farm so she's kind of
like a farm girl
and uh
they party a lot they'll have biker
parties at
in these barns and farms and [ __ ] maybe
100 people out there and [ __ ]
motorcycles everywhere and it's just
like any other scene they'll set up a
stage and get a pa system and [ __ ] uh
they have djs
and she plays um like hard rock music
metal type dj not
she knows all that western country
western [ __ ] but she doesn't go any more
country than say like zz top that that's
his country she's going to go which
isn't even country that's not really a
country that's just like southern russia
so she's got
pink hair and she looks kind of [ __ ]
goth in a certain way with
jeans and see if i can she is so show
picture show she's talking thank you
again zach
i hope actually good adaptations of
games become the next big thing i'm
hyped as [ __ ] for the hbo series based
on the last of us yeah that'd probably
be good because i've heard that's like
an x-ing game
um
yeah tila said jen i re-watched carrie
last night damn i love that movie it's
horrifically funny in a way too
we just rewatched that not too long ago
too matter of fact
uh jenny did you read the point horror
books no i have not
this is what
kind of like a country
biker
girl would look like or around here they
look like that
okay
thank you tila
for the super chat can you imagine a
remake of the birds with eggers
directing it he would do a great job and
make it more relatable and intense yeah
i can see that
i can see that
i mean
yeah john smith i actually agree with
you absolutely on this i'm a fan of the
idea of remaking uh remaking movies that
were like a good idea but didn't quite
work the first time and doing it better
yeah if it was done amazing the first
time like if they stuck the landing then
just leave it alone but there's lots of
movies that actually had a great concept
but for whatever reason because they
didn't have enough budget or it was the
wrong actor or something um or you know
the studio cut it up too much or
whatever
then you know you could totally like
remake that
uh bob apple says i still say x is the
best horror movie of the year that's
what i've been hearing so
i'm gonna wait till the price comes down
a little bit and then i'll rent it and
then i'll watch it
but yeah i've heard like a lot of really
good stuff about that i'm really trying
to like keep up i'm trying to keep up
with all the new horror movies and
trying to keep up with all the books and
[ __ ] like that but it's hard there's a
lot of new stuff coming out
that i want to see thank you for the uh
super chat t yeah i did that right i
just saw it
okay sorry look at this little thing
from dan bell there
yeah
yeah
well i'm on his uh patreon so oh do you
know dan bell and rick had a falling out
oh they did i think they've made up now
but from what i could have determined
like he put like this big long message
on patreon
and i guess
this is like kind of funny but him and
rick were doing one of the podcasts and
apparently they got into like this
really big like horrible argument on it
and
um
for a time i think dan was saying that
they weren't going to do another dirty
room anymore because he didn't want to
work with rick anymore because that's
like they just had this big [ __ ]
flame out and he actually even deleted
the podcast like for a long time because
he was like embarrassed about it because
dan dan
because they gotta like this big fight
about it but then like later on
i haven't listened to it like i think he
put it back up later but he's like yeah
me and rick are like talking but
they they actually got to a fight on the
podcast yeah
what were they fighting over i don't
know well i think it was the thing where
that drama that they were getting all
kind of i haven't listened to it but
from what he said yeah
um
i kind of feel like
i don't know if this is because i don't
know either one of them i can hear you
let me get some ice um
i don't know either one of them but from
what they said it's kind of like
rick has his own channel now and like
rick does kind of like this like what we
did he just hangs out in his backyard
like and his wife films him and he just
does like a live stream like on friday
nights or saturday nights or whatever it
is and he just like hangs out and talks
about a bunch of [ __ ] like we do and
like answers questions and stuff
and
i think that maybe his channel isn't
doing as well as he thought and i think
maybe he kind of blames dan for not
doing more to promote his channel
you know what i'm saying i kind of feel
like there's that kind of [ __ ] going on
you know what i mean because sometimes
rick will say some sideways [ __ ] to dan
like you need me or something like that
which is like kind of a joke but
i think he thinks that
because but that's the thing though like
dan was like kind of successful before
another dirty room i mean his dead mall
series i kind of feel like was the first
thing that
kind of got him attention right i mean
he did like a [ __ ] ted talk about it
and everything
i don't remember when another dirty room
came along and even all the another
another dirty room like don't have rick
on them like they're not all it's not
all rick now rick is funny
because he's shameless and he'll do
anything and he's gross yeah but um
which is very entertaining
but
i mean dan's entertaining on his own too
i like his i don't know if you guys know
but dan bell does um
every saturday night
he does a live stream
uh and he will pick a random person like
that's on his patreon he does a drawing
like at the beginning of every month and
if anybody like on his patreon list if
wanna want to like be on the live stream
he'll do a drawing and then like if you
can get to baltimore because that's
where he lives and hang out with him and
he'll and
so him and like a random patron will
just like drive around baltimore they're
like ex you know explore like abandoned
[ __ ] or like
get into all kind of shenanigans like on
saturday nights they're super fun and
they're usually like three to four hours
long they're just driving around
baltimore like shooting the [ __ ] it's
pretty funny
and let me see
motel hell somebody was talking about
yeah the birds
i haven't seen the birds for a while
that was based on a book too did people
know that i think it was daphne de
mourier was it not adriana says she
likes dan bill but he seems kind of
bipolar yeah he's got he he is he's got
problems he admits it i mean he talks
about it like pretty openly
on some of his shows
um he seems well he went through like a
bad patch a while back
where he didn't even and he kind of came
on later and was talking about it where
he was like having all kind of
depression and stuff like that but he's
had his uh medication regulated so he
seemed like a lot better
like the more recently like on the last
i haven't watched all of them because
they're long but sometimes i put them on
in the evenings like when i'm just like
you know laying around like falling
asleep or whatever and he seems like
he's in a kind of in a better place but
he does kind of go up and down he does
have but he's like i said he's pretty
open about talking about it
and
i don't know i kind of i'm kind of
curious to like listen to that podcast
for him and rick got on a
got in a fight
but
i kind of feel like that happens a lot
because as i said the dynamic between
them is
i feel like i feel like rick wants
because dan is like famous
and so i kind of feel like rick is like
why aren't you helping me out more or
like why aren't more of your fans like
watching my stuff and i think he's like
resentful because of that
but
yeah well there's a big big difference
why rick is great on another dirty room
when they're [ __ ] when when he's
doing all the tests and [ __ ] he's best
in a crowd
yeah you know
um
but it's kind of his show's got to be
kind of high energy
and he has to be [ __ ] kind of loaded
you know yeah
um
dan is [ __ ] soothing you can just put
dad on and he'll just talk yeah quiet
time and he'll [ __ ] go out and on
dark road and [ __ ] show the flash i
just drive around talking talking about
ghosts and [ __ ] yeah he has a very like
soothing voice right right
you just sit there and just zone out
and hear him talk
and he's very talented editor his dead
mall videos are just [ __ ] they were
the [ __ ] industry standard for years
there's a couple other channels that
were able to replicate his feel with
those vaporwave and everything he was a
little bit mad about that i kind of feel
like one of the latest
that's what i mean one of the later ones
that came along i think he was he didn't
mention him by name but he's like yeah i
saw this other channel that came up
recently that like was totally ripping
him off ripping off exactly
he couldn't produce enough yeah he
hasn't made any in years
so dude [ __ ] would step in and go
okay i'm gonna do a dead ball video he's
got all that footage and he doesn't he
doesn't [ __ ] edit
he doesn't make i mean i guess he's got
other [ __ ] to do too but it's gonna have
the [ __ ] to do
but no i think you know
it's a you know
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery yeah dan figured he knew how to
make a dead ball video
his are still the most entertaining yeah
although there's like i like um
i like sal
i like his good and his their dead mall
videos too but they're they have the
kind of their own thing going on like he
has it he doesn't try to make them like
dan's videos
you know i got burnt down on dead mall
videos so i watch them now they just
don't mesmerize me like they used to
just because
i finally internalized that the malls
are are going you know now the mall that
we go to here it's still going strong
but it's because the location they made
too many of them [ __ ] things that
that was part of the problem
and
you go to these malls now
and it's nothing but just chinese
[ __ ] junk trinkets there's it's
overpriced there's [ __ ] nothing there
and i'm looking around last time we were
there and i'm looking there's hardly any
english spoken
and [ __ ] all these people look like
they're new to the united states if you
ask me
and i don't know if there's some kind of
housing project around that area or
whatever
and i'm like why are they in this mall
are they in here
the food court [ __ ]
has a lot of [ __ ] it rocks it's
always has a lot of action but i'm like
who's buying this [ __ ] people that don't
have atm cards or something i think
everybody has
an atm or debit card now well the thing
about where that mall is like you said
it's in a really good location because
it's walkable
from several like big huge apartment and
townhouse complexes so i kind of feel
like it's just kind of a place where
they're getting hanging out let's just
go walk over there yeah if you don't
want to hang out in your house and
there's you know a food court and
there's the store the anchor stores all
have that same bland boring [ __ ] the
clothes are just bland all right
um everything most the the other stores
the inside are just
overpriced trinkets
there's a book store it's decent that
gets a lot of action yeah they have a
massive barnes and noble um i love that
place but a lot of the [ __ ] i look at it
and i go look
if i was on if i was a minimum wage
income earner
why the [ __ ] would i shop here when i
can go on amazon and get that for
delivered to me for a fraction of the
price
i mean the thing about it is that it's
it seems like it's mostly like clothing
and shoe stores but somebody must be
buying that [ __ ] because they're all
still open
i don't there's hardly anything oh they
just opened they opened a big apple
store in there i don't remember seeing
that that's why my head is kind of like
i'm like why are these people buying
this
you know i mean they don't speak english
they just got here okay
do they don't have atm card they don't
know about amazon why why would you
you're wasting your money buying that
that's what i'm looking at you know what
i mean well the thing about it though is
that maybe some particularly clothing
yeah i kind of feel like maybe some
people like to go buy clothing so they
can like try it on and see if it fits
because a lot of times and i've had this
happen too like ordering [ __ ] off amazon
and it looks really cool and then you
get it it doesn't fit right or something
like that so i kind of feel like that is
she bought that shirt there but that's a
t-shirt and it was it was in your in
their inner face you know what i mean
it's hard to go wrong with something
like that
the thing is is that what
most of that [ __ ] that they're selling
there is like that's like old lady
clothes
well maybe it's old ladies i guess i
don't know i'm just looking at i'm glad
i'm invited i'm just saying i was bummed
out though that the um the food court it
used to have a little indian place
and i was gonna get food there but it's
closed now but all the other ones are
open they have like a mediterranean
place that's where i ate at
and um like i got a greek salad and like
a
what do you call it like steak kind of
thing zach just sent in the five dollars
thank you zach thank you very much i
still wish dan and will karpinski still
work together yeah me too they had great
chemistry and will is cute as [ __ ] lmao
um which one was will
he was the one he was um he had real
dark hair and he was on like some of the
real early ones like when
um
you know who he is but yeah they had
some kind of falling out and i kind of
feel like dan won't say what it is
dan's new little boy toy i mean that
[ __ ] i don't know if he's on
some kind of hormone blockers or what
because he's got to be in his 20s but he
still looks like he's 15.
he's very youthful yeah his son i don't
know
what's that what's that kid's name i
can't remember what his name is i don't
know i like him
yeah he's cute as [ __ ] yeah he's he's a
good guy but you know he's got he'll be
on there like because the the one that i
saw the other day like the person that
won the patron thing patreon thing that
was supposed to go with him couldn't go
and so i guess he can call up i think
his name's dylan right so he can call up
dylan and say hey you want to go so he
can have like two people but it's funny
because like dylan doesn't really like
to be on
camera so it's just kind of so he's
always like really nervous it's like
really funny teens talking about fun
house that she just saw fun at yeah we
have we have it yeah we have that yeah i
grew up with that movie yeah we uh
reviewed it not too long i can tell you
stories about that that was before the
math mountain [ __ ] thing happened to
me
um i'm not a piece living in
um at the time that i first saw it i was
actually
living in long beach california
um because i lived there half the time
and then the summers i lived in
mississippi you know
getting traded off to my dad my mom i
was in military school
and we had hbo
and that [ __ ] came on hbo and for
and every time fun house was on i had to
see it
i was just obsessed with it
it's a [ __ ] weird ass movie
and uh
man
they would show i'd call him tad he
wasn't tad was the one in the jar the
pickled punk in the jar that was tad
but his older brother with the [ __ ]
split face
man [ __ ] me up
he was all pale
with the [ __ ] pink eyes he was like
an albino
he's trying to pay for a hand job from
that fortune teller hooker
so funny because like
as a kid i was seeing the fortune teller
i was like man he's gonna get a hand job
from that [ __ ] nasty looking old
witch that old lady i saw her recently
and i was like she's kind of hot
that's [ __ ] funny man
when you get older [ __ ]
your eyes change you know
yeah he's going like toby hooper that's
right t yeah yeah
are you you're just seeing that now i
grew up with that
that movie [ __ ] had an impact on me
and what was what was the bad what was
the what was the monster's name i'mma
call him the monster he was actually
kind of like a tragic
guy really you know [ __ ] what
happened yeah he couldn't help it he
couldn't really help what he was
man how he got killed he [ __ ]
got hung up by his shirt or his neck i
don't remember
his legs got drunk through that [ __ ]
those gears just crushed his looking
legs and he's grabbing her man
was he trying to kill her never really
made it clear did they i don't really
remember yeah
adriana says uh the lincoln park dan
bell documentary was creepy yeah he goes
back there like all the time yeah seedy
and sad is all baltimore like that
no but he likes to kind of like go to
those areas
uh because it's scarier tila says dead
and buried came out in 1980 yeah and
that was i have to yeah that's a great
[ __ ] moment another one that was that
i love
like spooked me as a kid i was saying a
kid i must have been 15 or 16 at the
time
not probably 15 14 15. and the entity
she brings up the entity yeah yeah
did we ever do i don't think we ever did
like a review review on that i think
like one of the first shows that we did
like way back in 2016
was
a comparison between the movie and the
actual case
right but i don't think we ever like
reviewed the actual movie i haven't seen
it in a long time
um and then they're talking about
the howling and wolfen honestly i've
been wanting to re-watch wolfen for a
while because i remember seeing that a
bunch on cable like back in the 80s but
i haven't seen it in probably like 20 or
30 years all right granthurst is asking
me another question he wants to know if
viagra works
i've never taken viagra uh i
took some cialis which is similar to it
my stepdad gave me a [ __ ] um
a sample
that he had he tried him he said they
didn't that [ __ ] doesn't work on me but
his health was really bad
and i had we had them things for a
couple years and then one day i said i'm
gonna [ __ ] take this [ __ ] jenny was
with me
damn this is how long ago was that five
six years something like that yeah right
jenny got sick of me quick
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] worked worked well
it did yeah yeah you just rock up you're
you'll rock up [ __ ] you do your
[ __ ] thing and then [ __ ] five
minutes later you're [ __ ] ready to go
again and then again and again you'll
you'll you'll a woman will get sick of
you on that [ __ ]
now
i never got any more of it i have access
to it it's expensive that's the problem
with it it's expensive it's like five
dollars a pill
a lot of guys that have problems uh with
with any kind of ed it's almost it's
usually your entry system uh if your
testosterone is low or if your [ __ ]
hormones are out of balance you're gonna
have that
um there's times where [ __ ] my
testosterone level gets too high
and [ __ ] you'll lose you'll lose
interest in sex and if you're not
interested you're going to have e.d
because you're just not in the [ __ ]
mood you just get too [ __ ]
you get too [ __ ] male you're just too
manly for sex
[Laughter]
you have to have a high enough estrogen
level
because men have estrogen too you have
to have a high enough estrogen level to
[ __ ]
and everything has to be in a certain
balance for you to be [ __ ] good to go
so sometimes when i'm [ __ ] around
with my [ __ ]
um
if i'm going on some kind of cycle like
when straw will kind of do if i've been
on winstrawl for a while
my entry consistently get kind of [ __ ]
up especially if i'm not [ __ ]
shooting hcg
which is a pituitary gland stimulant
which i get that too
which is much better than colombia this
is getting complicated for people who
aren't dude
some people like why the [ __ ] do you do
all this [ __ ] okay
if your t
why the [ __ ] are you putting false teeth
in your head when you become an old man
and your [ __ ] teeth fall out they're
supposed to be out right because you're
old you're supposed to gum on food right
no put [ __ ] false teeth in there it's
the same thing when you become an old
man and you just your android consistent
just doesn't [ __ ] make the hormones
that you used to make you know you get
heartburn your [ __ ] joints feel like
[ __ ]
your [ __ ] sex drive [ __ ] sucks you
know what i mean
and you start losing muscle mass and
getting fatter and fatter you go that's
just a part of getting old no [ __ ] no
just start injecting synthetic hormones
into your body and your body will start
running like it did
it's called technology
the problem with this [ __ ] is that it's
expensive
it has to be administered by a doctor or
these clinics i was going to a clinic
okay
and you have to know what you're doing
you have to understand how to manually
regulate your endocrine system
and it's
some of it's trial and error because not
everybody's exactly the same you just
got to see how you work
it's like the hormonal version of false
teeth and or glasses
you're you're applying
manually the hormones that you used to
make normally and the body starts
growing like it did i don't get
heartburn anymore my [ __ ] joints feel
great
my [ __ ] spine is real flexible and
just jump down the ground jump up and
down roll around you used to be like oh
man oh man
all that's gone
um
libido is good pretty good but you can
[ __ ] that up if you start overdoing it
like man i want to gain another two or
three pounds you know and you're sitting
there and injecting [ __ ] going i'm gonna
take a little bit heavier dose this time
and then you go out there and work out
and
healing up good but then you realize
you're the terminator now you know what
i mean you're like nah [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] affection
i'm gonna play with this machine you
know i mean you start getting like a
[ __ ] uh
uh extreme male brain yeah extreme male
brain
and you get real snappy and touchy you
know
that is not centered put seat think
there it is it's all the same size now
see
spatial awareness getting you
irritation so you have to [ __ ]
understand
how it works what you're going to do
what you're going to be like
i've been offered some [ __ ] we're like
you know
yeah
i think i am going to get that trend
but then you start thinking about it you
start listening to what happened to
other dudes because you know you go on
trend
trend trend balloon is cheap
you'll burn every ounce of fat off you
pretty quickly
you can gain a lot of muscle quickly you
just heal up superhuman rate
but it might make you want to kill
people
you know it may want it may make you
want to strangle a [ __ ] in a
field i definitely don't need that so
you start going like yeah
oh and another thing is is that [ __ ]
you may have [ __ ] erectile
dysfunction for about a month but it'll
pass you know he just started going man
maybe i want i'm not gonna do this
it's stick with the [ __ ]
that is close to what biology gave you
testosterone bunch of the different
testosterone esters hcg and clomid
you do a little bit of wind straw a
little bit of anavar the light [ __ ] you
know i've done a little bit of dead ball
before
daddy ball was great make you look fat
though especially in the face they just
kind of puff you up and even the
injectable i was using injectable
it's just
everything has a trade-off
and you don't want to [ __ ] take that
i'm not giving the medical advice this
is just anecdotal [ __ ] this is all this
is all [ __ ] theory theoretical
never go with really high doses to try
to make some kind of fast transformation
in like a in a month or two or three
month period nah you want it to be
low doses over a long period of time
something that you know the change
happens over a year six months something
like that or a few months or something
kind of gradual because that's how the
body was designed to act you start doing
this thing where that some of these high
schoolers were doing grammaticals back
we were kids we remember those dudes
they get there and they just [ __ ]
jack themselves up they're [ __ ] 17
the [ __ ] put on 10 pounds in a
month
look like a monster
but that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] them up
and then when when that hormone was gone
then they got fat
and it's be just because of all that
the endocrine system trying to find a
balance after all that you know
everything has to be just steady even
the body does not like abrupt changes
and that's that's the basic rule
but viagra
does not work
on dudes
that have poor health
and just [ __ ]
no hormones and
um
and another thing is the second some
dudes are just trying to have sex with
their wife and they haven't been
attracted their wife in [ __ ] decades
you know what i mean it's just it's not
gonna work you know
you're gonna need professional help
her her name might be candy her name
might be susie you're gonna need some
kind of professional help
[Laughter]
if you're not gonna be able to you know
that has some some
thing to do with it too you know you
your wife might need some [ __ ] extra
correctoral activities or something you
know extra extracurricular activities
yeah
yeah i'm a big drinker
me too but i can still talk so far you
all might need a girlfriend or something
so you can go something you can spice it
up with
granthar's also asked name the best
movie clint howard was in uh the evil
i'm also kind of like a big fan of the
ice cream man it's a terrible movie but
the rifftrax version was i like the eve
was amazing yeah the evil is actually
pretty good good movie it's cheesy as
[ __ ] but it's actually like cheesy and
the best possible it was a good
ghost slasher type horror movie haunted
house movie i liked it
but with technology
what what kind of what not the evil not
the evil that wasn't the one i was
thinking of i was thinking of the one
that was the
evil was the one from the scene the one
with the computer where he was like
trying to speak evil speak that was good
too okay yeah it was also good evil
speak evil speak yeah that was good i
liked that one not the evil
clint howard wasn't an evil yeah evil
speak that's what i was talking about
uh what was the best day of your life
jeez oh who's asking this granthars uh
i might have to get back to you on that
yeah i can't such thing i mean i can't
really think of anything like i've had a
bunch of awesome [ __ ] happen but yeah
it's like really hard to like think i've
had lots of awesome [ __ ] happen i've
like had a lot of shitty [ __ ] happen too
but i kind of feel like everybody's
gonna have that
um
did you ever see the prowler i saw that
uh scanners has got better with age i
would yeah i need to kind of watch that
only scanners won the rest of them
sucked
i don't remember the other ones the
other ones weren't uh
weren't the same director
saw scent i thought scanners 2 was good
because i when i was a kid and i went or
watched it recently it was unwatchable
unwatchable
i mean we're talking about as bad as as
[ __ ] transfers
remember how unwatchable
hey you were the one that said that
recommended the trans who recommended
transit she was like oh i remember this
maybe being really good and then we
watched
it shit's funny that's terrible
what were you supposed to do
when you're a kid you're a lot more
tolerant to [ __ ] low quality bad
writing you know
that is one good thing about getting
older and you're a little more
discerning yeah but the thing about it
though is that sometimes too i kind of
feel like i'm trying not to lose
the thing where you just kind of like
appreciate a bad movie you know what i'm
saying
i'll just watch a bad movie if it's fun
because like i said i like roof tracks
and mst and all that kind of stuff so
i'm very very used to watching bad
movies and there's something really
endearing
about certain types of bad movies and i
don't ever want to like lose that i
don't want to get like too snotty but
it's like oh well this is grandpa's
asked me how many times i've been in a
fist fight i've been in pro probably a
dozen of them uh
half of them lost half of my lost
because it was almost always a guy
bigger than me or i was outnumbered
uh how many how many dead people have
you seen including not funerals uh
probably about 30 or 40 50 of them maybe
um
on one occasion that no it must have
been more than that more about 60 60 or
70 of them probably
because
on one event there was a whole busload
of dead ones and that must have been
30 people right there
um yeah i remember no i was looking at
him talking to people as they died
looking in their eyes and [ __ ] from
[ __ ] mis uh accidents
me and jenny were riding back and
[ __ ]
ended up in a car pile up and i was
looking at the dude in the truck next to
me when a [ __ ] car hit him at about
80 and he just instantly killed one i
mean we were in we were in the pilot
yeah we weren't just going well wakanda
it was piling up around us yeah and then
i drove through it
looking right at that dude's eyes when
the [ __ ] car hit him and he just
vanished off into the abyss
um and i and i turned and i was drunk i
said we got to get out of here and
jimmy's like yeah
[Laughter]
bunch up i seen a bunch a bunch of dead
ones
um
oh
yeah that's all i'm gonna say about that
yeah
some of them were homicides some of the
[ __ ] just happened in the army
um
some of the [ __ ] ended up in the
newspaper uh dude went nuts and [ __ ]
blew away the [ __ ] first sergeant and
[ __ ] three or four guys and then
himself at the in the unit next to us
while we were out in the [ __ ] party
however you're telling me yeah i watched
the [ __ ] cops gunned down a [ __ ]
dude out in the parking lot one time
when the mps gunned him down fort
campbell he had a [ __ ] samurai sword
and they [ __ ] gunned him down it was
some stupid [ __ ] and then
that we went to war with the mps for
about two years after that
and we had a sniper who was shooting the
mps with the 22
when they'd go by we never could figure
out who that was doing it there was
somebody in our unit
and the mps [ __ ] raided our barracks
and [ __ ]
i may know who it was but i ain't gonna
say
that's all i'm gonna say about it
i think i know who it was but i don't
have any evidence
and um
somebody was randomly shoot at the
[ __ ] mps at fort cavill as they
passed
the barracks next to us
and they [ __ ] raided that place three
times trying to see who that was he
didn't hit anybody but he would hit the
windshield
it was either a 22 or a pellet gun they
don't know
what it was
i think it might have been a 22.
we're talking about the movie the fury
uh fury was good too hasn't exploding oh
that's my phone oh is it that was i
thought it was a door opening no
my phone was buzzing uh the fury was
good too has an exploding head as well
you gotta wait for a while for it yeah
it doesn't happen until the end
um yeah john cassavetes is in that yes
he is
and
[Music]
did did brian de palma
direct that or am i crazy
maybe
incubus that was another movie that i've
been wanting to like review for a while
i kind of feel like i put it in the
[ __ ] pole a few times but it doesn't
didn't win
when was the last time you got ripped
off or hustled by a con man i never got
ripped off for hustle but i can't
remember a single
really the only thing that i've had
happen like that was like well it wasn't
even like that but somebody like used my
credit card to like buy three thousand
dollars worth of computer equipment but
they got caught so
i've never i've never had myself like
another drink
yeah i'm not saying like oh i'm so smart
i wouldn't fall for it i've just never
been in that situation
[Laughter]
tila says who doesn't want the power to
scan i would oh i would totally abuse
that i would totally abuse that because
well see the best thing about it was
that you would have total plausible
deniability no one would believe well i
guess
that's the thing in a universe where
scanners existed unless it was like
super super top secret which i guess it
would have to be
um you could have that power and you
could still totally have like plausible
deniability so like somebody was like
pissing you off on the bus or something
like that it's like
[ __ ] i'm gonna blow your head up
and then you would [ __ ] do it and
they'd just be like what
his head just blew up but it's i don't
have any idea what happened
you know what i mean um you know i just
i i would totally blow everyone's head
up all the time
i would have blown up so many people's
hats
[Music]
i've crushed
[Music]
that's what i'm saying i would totally
abuse it and like i said i would get if
if in that universe like everybody knew
about it i would get in big trouble
because i'd be like blowing up heads all
over the place like left and right but
if it was like top secret and nobody
knew that i could blow up heads then i
would absolutely be blowing up heads all
the time
yes okay brian de palma did direct the
period that's what i thought
sometimes i'm like afraid to say things
out loud because i'm like i kind of i
was like i kind of feel like i know this
information but then if i say it out
loud and i'm wrong i'll feel like really
stupid
so i'm like really like reluctant
rebecca says i'm married a con man joy
is of me yeah it does happen it does
happen [ __ ] man we see that kind of crap
on like unsolved mysteries all the time
like sometimes you get like this dude
and he's like super suave and he's like
all this kind of there was one on there
i mean we've been watching like the old
unsolved mysteries but this is probably
from like the 80s or the 90s and this
guy
and he i don't remember what he said his
job was um but he had seemed to have
money at a boat he had all this other
kind of stuff and he starts dating this
whoop and it was like a while and then
allegedly uh she disappeared i kind of
feel like he probably murdered her and
pushed her off the phone at some point
but
he they found out that he totally wasn't
like who he said he was
and that happens like alarmingly often
and sometimes the dudes will be like
they'll be in it for like a year or two
like for a long time
so
you know
you meet a guy that seems like cool and
everything
and you know if you get some red flags
immediately yeah but it's like you
you're with a guy for like a year two
years something like that and he seems
totally normal and then all of a sudden
you figure out oh my god he's actually a
serial killer who also has like three
other families like across the united so
which does happen holy [ __ ] i can't
imagine i can't imagine what that would
be like some people must be really
really good at [ __ ]
compartmentalize or something i don't
know
um
one of these days you should review the
film deadly blessing which is wes craven
honestly i've put that in the poll
three times four times and it never wins
because it
you don't know it probably well i put it
on
i put it in the poll i started putting
the poll because i think it came up on
either 2b or amazon prime on for free
and i was like oh yeah i remember that
movie that's the old west kramen movie
and i kind of feel like a lot of people
haven't uh seen it i haven't seen it
since the 80s
and so i was like okay so i'll put it in
the poll but i keep putting the poll but
it never wins i guess because
i don't know
i that's why we started doing like the
live matinees because a lot of times i
like
that um you know that i can have a poll
so people that are patrons have
like they feel like they're getting
something special like they can vote on
something but
then there's a lot of movies that i kind
of want to review that we never really
get around to because patrons we got to
get those shirts done because it's time
for a mail out for the shirts
and um i want to get i promised and he's
on right now promise bee's nest i'd get
a [ __ ] ocp shirt which weird got that
ready we got i made it i got the design
i just haven't done the screen i got to
make the screen i got to get the the
thing to do the screen
and then i'll product put in production
i want to do an ocp design
and what was the other one wanted to do
a [ __ ] canon film canon studio i did
that one too yeah that is a cool looking
[ __ ] logo and they're out of business
so that [ __ ]
would be
only a [ __ ] true film [ __ ] buff
would
look it was canon the other one was
corello right what was it
i think it's
correlated which is similar like the
logo looks kind of similar it's a little
spirally see they're the little logos we
grew up with and it and they they are
very good in one color like black or
white on a black shirt they'd look
really good
and what was the other one
it was ocp or omni consumer products
from from
robocop
corelco and [ __ ] candy films and they
look really good
yeah
but i want to get those out and i want
to offer those to the
to the subscribe to the uh patrons and
then they'll we'll offer them for a uh
probably twenty dollars a pop depending
on the size if you're not a patron in
the super chats yeah
and they should sell well and i'll have
uh sleeve or sleeveless versions too and
pry some girl versions
some some teddy shirts i know you girls
want to show them titties off
well i mean here's the thing
about t-shirts is that and this t-shirt
here
when you go because i got this at fye in
the mall
this is a man shirt because they didn't
have girl shirts but was so when they
have a manager that they actually they
had a cthulhu one that i really wanted
but they didn't have a small if i have
to get a man cut i have to get a small
because if i get anything bigger than a
small in-man cut then it's like super
baggy and makes me look as big as a
[ __ ] house
because
women's shirts are fitted
men's shirts are just hang there because
men don't have boobies usually
so
i mean depending on
well depending on the man somebody is
yeah that's what i'm saying so you know
no shame i'm just saying that uh yeah so
most men don't have boobs so so the
shirts are just kind of like straight
down but they don't have like you know
they don't have curvature
so uh so i would prefer to have a
t-shirt that was more
fitted because it looks better
but
sometimes beggars can't be choosers and
all they will do
because the man shirt is like the
default so you gotta get so i always
have to get a small
now interestingly they had a lot of
really cool shirts at fye i'm gonna say
they had i bought you know um if you
guys have seen like because i've worn it
on this show a bunch of times the
creature from the black lagoon one which
i love that shirt i got that there
and they had one like that but it was
for jaws um but they didn't have it
yesterday when i was there but they did
have the cthulhu one but unfortunately
they only had three of them left and
they were all extra extra large in man's
size and i'm like okay i can't get that
now the other one that i wanted was they
had one that was like gray and it had
like the
like a stylized like jason mask on it
and it said camp crystal lake like
running team or something like that and
it was like super cute and i was like oh
i kind of want that but they were out
um
so
then i saw this one like on another
rack
and i was just kind of like oh that's
kind of nice even though it's long
sleeve then it's floored and it's hot so
they had this one and they had a
hellraiser one they had a cool exorcist
one too but
the design was cool but the shirt was
like green like dark green
like not a nice green either and i was
just kind of like
am i ever really gonna wear that
probably we should do we should do a
cthulu design too
yeah yeah we could yeah uh
hornet i'll send you a uh a corralco too
when if you when you see the corralco
logo you'll you'll you'll recognize it
you'll recognize it yeah let me write
that down because yeah i don't want to
forget yeah don't forget that
you know and then i'll get those screens
printed up because i got i got screen
material and all kinds of [ __ ] i'll make
it that was
print them up print them up to order
we'll get them out there
yeah because i want some too running out
t-shirts
uh you made the best choice with the
creep show shirt i'm really actually
this was in the whole store because they
have like all the shirts in the front
but then they also had a bunch of shirts
like on racks like throughout the store
and i didn't really have time to look at
all of them this was literally the only
one of these shirts that they had left
and i was like really really lucky that
this was a small because most of the
ones that they had there were like
really really big like extra large and i
can't wear those
i mean i can but they're giant
and they kind of like go down on my
knees and [ __ ] so i was super super
happy that i found this one he's talking
about exorcist shirts and then uh
rebecca's talking about v-neck it's more
flattering on a woman's shirt
how many
how many choices of [ __ ] women's
shirts do we have um
all of them we have all of them you can
get
v-neck you can get scoop neck you can
get spaghetti strap you can get tank top
you can get a tank top that's like x
shape in the back or you can get tank
top that's like straight you can get i
mean i get all of our blank shirts from
jiffy shirts and they have 40 bajillion
different options we can look into some
better
selections options for the females i
mean it depends on how i would even mind
doing spaghetti strap shirts for girls
those things look good you'd probably
look good in something like that i have
some like that i did one um i think i
did an obscure one like that for the for
obscura undead i have one like that
because i still have all the and i can
do all the old designs that we have in
that
you know i mean so
we can do them to order
that way we don't have to work because
we already have a pretty big uh we
in my gym over here that closet it's a
big closet in there is all the screen
printing stuff and we must have [ __ ]
100 t-shirts 200 t-shirts of different
well i don't know if we have that many
but
we do have
yeah maybe about 100 yeah i mean and i'd
still have to like buy more probably
because
i always buy more
man's medium shirts because that's what
you wear yeah cause i'll have [ __ ]
six of the same ones and i always buy
more women's
small or women's spaghetti straw because
that's what i like to wear yeah cause
like i said i like the smaller ones just
because they're
tighter and if i get something bigger
because my boobs are so big like it'll
hang it'll make me look enormous like
unless i get something really small and
fitted you know what i'm saying so
there's that
but it depends on the shirt too
you know cause i've gotten some small
shirts that were too small
you know what i mean yeah uh you know
they weren't long enough or the sleeves
were too tight or something like that
but i don't usually as long as it's
small or medium i don't usually have too
much trouble
yeah yeah yeah okay i got my nephew that
shirt camp crystal lake swimming tape
yeah yeah yeah that's it that was the
one i kind of wanted that one too but
they didn't have any left they had it
like up on the wall and i was like
looking for it and they didn't have it
and they had also had these other cool
ones that were like
they looked like they were black shirts
and then they had
it looked like kind of um
i don't know like children's book covers
but they were horror
related so there was one and they were
like 70s looking so there's one it was
like a drawing and it was just like
let's give hugs or something like that
with two little kids like playing on a
sidewalk and then there was like the
alien like over them like going like
that so they had like a bunch like that
they had one like that that was alien
they had a halloween one
and then they had one other one and i
can't remember what it was but they had
like a bunch of like funny
uh horror movie shirts and i kind of i
like that kind of [ __ ] but i'm really
really happy that i found this one and
i'm really happy the hellraiser one's
cool too maybe i'll wear that one on
sunday like for the next show because
that one's super cool too and look it
has like stuff on the sleeves
like that's like it's
japanese and on there and then it
has like that
i like that this shirt at the bottom if
you can't solution
it has um what's-her-face's head
say like the cake
and it has fluffy on there
yeah super cool [ __ ] from the crate all
that i liked it that's good
uh only horror shirts i have says tila
are halloween jaws and dracula i'm
trying to think of all the ones i have i
have i'm gonna just we're gonna have a
santilla shirt one of these days yeah
you sent us your size taylor i'll send
you a shirt i have a omen one which is
like a baseball shirt that has like a
big
damian on it
i haven't oh um i have
one from
lucio fulchi's zombie that has like the
front says zombie and says we're gonna
eat you on it
uh that one's spaghetti strap
i have a couple hp lovecraft ones those
aren't really horror movie ones per se
i have a dead ringers one that i made
like a design that i made
that says uh
mantle twins fertility clinic on it
and
[Music]
i can't remember
i have like some kind of like random
ones like i have a vampire killing kit
one i have
a clockwork orange one that's not really
a horror movie but you know i have a
clockwork orange one
i have a lot of music shirts like a lot
of band shirts
although a lot of band shirts that i
have
um
i bought them a long time ago like when
i used to go to a lot more concerts when
i was much
uh heftier
so a lot of those shirts are
really big so i don't usually wear them
unless you know unless i'm gonna sleep
in them or something like that because
they're like really really giant
because now if i'm gonna like buy a
shirt i'll usually buy like i said a
smaller medium
but back then i would buy like extra
large and they were like because i liked
baggy shirts back then
uh suspiria shirt and blacula shirt
would be cool too honestly i always
wanted a suspiria shirt i had one that
was um i used to have one a long time
ago
but
i don't love the suspiria shirt that
they have like for such an iconic movie
i don't love that
poster you know the one like with the
white kind of like figure like standing
up on the toe shoes like with the blood
coming out like it's good like it's
minimalist but
suspiria like it's so visually arresting
that i really wish
that they would do some shirts with like
some cooler
i've seen some really cool like i don't
even know if they're on there anymore
but i saw them like a long time ago
somebody on amazon for a little while
like an artist
had done a bunch of like unauthorized
suspiria posters and a lot of them were
like really cool they were like art and
like super detailed like art nouveau
style
and i loved those and i was like [ __ ]
man if he made t-shirts out of those i
would buy all of that [ __ ] but i don't
even think the posters are available
anymore because they were like limited
edition but they were so so beautiful
and i just kind of feel like
i don't know like i used to have that
suspiria shirt that had that design on
it but i was just kind of like i don't
love that design though i just wanted
more out of it
i just wanted a more elaborate i like
really elaborate kind of [ __ ] but i
don't usually like minimalist
stuff not always it can be done well
i'm more i'm more like a very gothic
baroque type of person i like stuff
that's like real
detailed you know but
uh you know what are you gonna do tila
says i wanted to send you all some dvds
but do you have a p.o box we don't but
i mean you know if you message me on
facebook or something like that um i'll
send you our home address i don't have a
problem with that i know you're not
going to stalk us or nothing
we've done that before
and
we have a channel in the uk called
talking pictures says mango every friday
night they do a horror triple bill
ew that's cool
yeah holy parish of doom who says his
name is peter by the way he's like holy
parachute that's just my channel name
uh 90s xl shirts were huge yeah they
really were and i can't really do
you know when i was younger i really
really liked those big baggy t-shirts
but it's just like i
i don't really like to wear those
anymore yeah they're comfortable but
like i said they make me look [ __ ]
five feet wide so no thanks
um
i have a killer salem lot t-shirt that
sounds cool
i mean
suspiria should be on a black tea with
very saturated blues and pinks and a
black gloved hand of the witch coming
after jessica harper
yeah and honestly like on my computer
um
even on this computer and my other
computer my uh my what do you call it
background screen
is that
scene from suspiria with jessica harper
like and she's in the room like looking
all like terrified with the peacock
thing like on the side because i love
that [ __ ] shot so it's like there's
so much cool [ __ ] in that movie that you
can make a t-shirt out of and i don't
know why they don't
the poster is just like so it's okay but
it's just so minimalist i'm just not
into it
especially because the movie is just so
over the top like with the visuals i
don't know why they would do just like
that minimalist like white red well i
know why because it's cheaper but you
know
uh
i'm still jacked over the north man i
want to see that [ __ ] again
no matter when the blu-ray is going to
be out
probably won't be too long i bet you'd
have a longer director's cut
probably although that movie was like
pretty long but although like it's like
another hour it didn't really seem that
long
that went by fast to be honest with you
like i said i looked it up before
and i told you before i was like oh it's
two hours and 17 minutes because when
you buy the amc ticket it tells you how
long the movie is
but i was like oh i'll probably have to
get a drink beforehand or otherwise i'm
going to like dive dehydration that was
constant but
yeah it's like i did
it did not totally seem that because i
was like why it's oprah already
the time just flew by
you know what the weird thing about that
so that movie had been playing for
several weeks at that point
so there were probably only um
what like
eight or nine other people in the
theater something like that
and it's like you know
you can buy your tickets ahead of time
nowadays it's not like the old days
where you could just wander and sit
anywhere
everybody sat in the same row as us yeah
another people behind us why do people
do that because we had that's a good row
but there were people behind us though
when i go to buy tickets if i go to buy
tickets and there's like people here
here here i'm like okay i'm going as far
away from those people because people
like talk and they breathe and they chew
they probably thought it was going to
fill up
but and it's like i don't want to listen
what amazes me is that after the after
the movie is over everybody was quiet
yeah i didn't hear a peep
and i was like worried i was getting
ready to clap
[Laughter]
yeah
that reminded me that reminds me of one
of those [ __ ] is it geico those geico
commercials like don't turn into your
parents and somebody like claps at the
end of the movie and the guy's like the
people who made the movie aren't here
you know what i mean and i'm just kind
of like yeah but some sometimes people
do he's seeing himself going up to
valhalla the valkyries riding him up
there on the [ __ ] horses and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] it just boom that's it i was
like yeah
[ __ ] went to valhalla
he made it he made it
no yeah
i thought that was funny but yeah so
it's like we got there kind of early
because like i said we got in we went uh
to the mall and everything so we were
there like probably like 20 minutes when
the movie started
and we were the only ones in there for a
while and we were like right in the
middle like in row e like right before
where the uh handicap spots are because
then you can like lean your feet on the
railing and there's no seats in front of
you
and then like five minutes before the
movie started another couple with their
teenage kid i think
came in and sat in the seats right next
to us
the [ __ ] was like empty
they wanted to get a good and they came
right there i'm like
i like that you guys i like that part
where they kept showing the damn norse
life tree
and then they they zoom in on it and he
sees his ancestors and they're dead
yeah and then he see then he sees
himself and [ __ ] all right they seized
his his children that hadn't been born
yet later on that [ __ ] was awesome i was
like going yeah that's what it's like
you guys [ __ ] look people do me a
favor because i can't um
i don't really want to [ __ ] close the
window what's the name of that
norse life tree that's in the that's in
in the edius
yeah it's
something like that some kind of a life
tree
it's the tree of tree of life type of
deal it's in there it's in it's in the
mythos
yeah the edius talks about it i just
forgot what it's called
it's going to have many different names
it's gonna an english name and a norse
name
yeah peter says isn't that annoying i
know it's like the whole [ __ ]
seriously there was like 15 people in
their tops
and they came and sat right there and i
was worried because here's what always
happens to me i don't like other people
okay so it's like i'm and especially if
i'm in a movie y'all better shut the
[ __ ] up because i don't want to hear a
[ __ ] peep out of you like the whole
time because i'm watching the movie i
paid for this [ __ ] don't talk
so
you know don't breathe don't chew don't
do anything
so they come and like sit right there
and
i'm always kind of worried because
i'm not gonna yell at people for talking
during the trailers i don't love it um
because i'm kind of watching the
trailers too
but
if somebody's talking
at a normal volume during the trailers i
always suspect that they're probably
going to talk at normal volume during
the movie as well and i'm always kind of
like oh it always just like makes my
[ __ ]
skin crawl and i'm just like am i gonna
have to hit this [ __ ] because
they're gonna talk to her and so the guy
was talking during the trailers
i also don't like it when people like
comment on the trailers like after the
trailer is over they're like oh that
looks good like really that's i'm like
dude shut up nobody cares what you think
okay yeah they've come down the answer
is called yebrasil that's what i said
yeah
yeah okay that's what i said you have
there i have a font called that you know
that's like a norse rooney yeah that's
how i remembered it because i because i
knew i had a font that was named after
it
i forgot what the whole [ __ ] me
there's a lot of [ __ ] to that movie i
was watching it and i was like well how
deep are they gonna go off into this
there's a scene when they jump on the
roost and they go into that roost
[ __ ] village
the
the vikings are like trying to be cool
and talk the [ __ ] children out of the
hands of the the mamas
and they're like no no no hell no hell
no they're [ __ ] taking the babies
anyway and putting the children in the
barn and they set them on fire
and i was like yeah that was the easy
way though what another thing they used
to do is
collect all the children and then make
the children fight each other to the
death
and they would be like
laughing and betting on them and stuff
and they thought that was great fun and
then like the few
that would survive they would keep those
uh like okay you're strong enough you
know
they were [ __ ] brutal those dudes
were not a joke
uh try to think of what else they did to
children they also had a i can't
remember his name you guys can google
him
it was you know some viking name and
then they called him the child lover
uh
that doesn't bode too well does it it
was
well they called him the child lover
because he was constantly trying to stop
them from killing the children during
the raids and they would like kind of
make it and they were like [ __ ] with
him because yeah yeah yeah you child
come on we're killing the little kids
yeah they were like it's fun well they
didn't understand it they couldn't
understand it you know what i mean that
he would
try to
try to save the children and try to talk
people out of killing them and uh
trying to [ __ ] you know whatever he
was actually the only person yeah yeah
he would try to make excuses on why we
shouldn't do this but they he was kind
of like they were like lame
but he was let me talk but he's supposed
to be [ __ ] heroic let you talk yeah
let me he was supposed to be he's
allowed to interrupt me
she does it too
she he was supposed to be heroic in
battle so they respected him but they
just thought it was just mind-blowing
that he
was constantly trying to save these kids
and make excuses of why they shouldn't
kill him and [ __ ]
which um
i thought about it and i was like well
in those days you probably couldn't let
them live
if you did they'd come back and get your
ass
so much like you see in this book just
like you seen this movie so it's
probably the vikings knew what they were
doing best was is if you raided a
village was just to kill everybody
you know
kill everybody and then just enslave the
women and take them with you then you
don't have nobody doing like an epic
journey nobody comes back revenge on
your rights
so
i guess it was just the uh it was the
morals of the time yeah well if you're
going to raid this [ __ ] town there
can't be any survivors really
or it just causes more trouble
so which that's what this movie's about
you got to kill all the children
basically and that's really how this
movie starts if you they let one of them
live and he came back and got your ass i
mean they killed everybody
well they didn't really let him live it
was kind of got away it was uh it was a
deception by one of the dudes
so there's that i don't want to really
ruin it but you know yeah yeah murder
hornet says kill them all like that's
one sort of amount and then uh peter
says isn't that a central part of uh
what's one of the hercules movies mst
riffs on
oh it might be
they did a bunch of hercules movies
i'd have to go back and watch i can't
remember which one that is
yeah so oh but what i was saying before
was that
so these three people sat like literally
right next to us right
before the movie started and i was like
[ __ ] me and i was like should i move and
then like some other people came and
like sat on the other side of us except
like two or three seats over i'm like
great now i can't get up to go to the
bathroom awesome
because now we're like surrounded
uh so there was that and then but i will
say that even though the guy talked all
during the [ __ ] commercials and all
during the trailers i didn't hear him um
once the movie started at least he shut
up most people don't
i've found that if people talk through
the trailers then they will absolutely
talk to them ethan hawke was the guy who
starred in this right
well he was um he was the kid right he
was the dad he was the dad yeah yeah so
he was like in it briefly like right now
yeah that was ethan yeah
which everybody looked good man
everybody was in good shape [ __ ] the
dude that played the prince [ __ ] he
was [ __ ] stacked he was looking real
good and i don't think that was cg
either i don't think they touched him up
i think that's how he was looking he was
looking lean he was looking very lean
and he was [ __ ] looking pretty big
um now
you're talking about a damn nearer
retelling the conan all right with a
different
with with a different tone a more
satanic black metal kind of [ __ ]
pagan [ __ ] horror folk horror [ __ ]
you guys i've done like so many cd
covers for bands that are into this kind
of yeah i mean they got it right
but uh he's like uh
he was looking
rivalling arnold
in terms of [ __ ] physical [ __ ]
physical being impressive physically
even though arnold was [ __ ] huge
in in conan
he was twice the size
he was in conan he was twice the size of
what he was and [ __ ] say uh
predator
even though i gotta say predator one
arnold was looked his best arnold didn't
look really all that good huge he looked
a bit he looked better a little
smaller a little thinner like he did in
in uh don't you agree in in predator i
think he look remember predator one
yeah i think he looked he was it had
been 40 pound 30 pounds lighter than
that
versus conan one i think he looked a
little bit better
i don't know tila's into him tila do you
look better in in conan one or predator
you you tell me i think you look better
in predator
so size isn't everything that's what i'm
getting at it's uh
i just
you know what i mean it's proportions i
thought he looked a little bit better
[ __ ] lighter
and uh yeah dude was looking good
[ __ ]
in this movie
the guy that played the northmen was
one thing that struck me about him was
how tall he was yeah he was a lot taller
than like everybody else like not
freakishly but enough that he was well i
mean through the whole thing he's kind
of like they kept calling him like the
beast and stuff like that
but he looks strong though yeah he did
not [ __ ] yeah he was a big [ __ ]
yeah but not like you know not like
voided out you're right but he was
though yeah but yeah but i mean not like
not like
right not like a boss he was just like
really really tall
and really really muscular and strong
yeah
look like it was
not even quite
not even quite what you would call the
bodybuilding world
classic physique not even that big
but bigger than say men's physique he
just looked good he looked like
he looked realistic it looked like a
dude could get that big and that strong
you know naturally which they can't but
it looks like it
tila said when we saw the north men it
was practically a full theater and
collapsed at the end of it yeah yeah and
then you t agree with me says he liked a
better predator tom he looked fine and
prettier yeah and he was
lighter in predator than he was in uh
in in in in conan even though i thought
he looked great in conan too but i think
he looked a little better in predator
and [ __ ] arnold
was a [ __ ] monster he was a monster
people forget how big he was
before he became an actor
when he was doing olympia he was [ __ ]
huge
at a young age
which god that got to be really bad on
your heart but
they didn't know back then they just
took all that [ __ ] and [ __ ] worked
out from god giant they're like yeah
we'll worry about it later when we're
old if we get old if it gets to that a
lot of those dudes died yeah they they
had a heart attack yeah yeah
fry your [ __ ] heart valves up you're
not meant to be that big it's really
hard on your heart it's not the drugs
it's the size
yeah yeah yeah i mean it's mass it's
mass and somebody in your heart has to
like pump blood through all of these all
that damn mass it [ __ ] your whether
it's fat or muscle your heart doesn't
really much care
it's hard i mean it's harder to pump it
through the muscle than it is fat
because muscle has a lot more blood
vessels so it's better to be thick it's
better to be fat it hits in some way
it's better to be i mean it's not use
you know don't be fat but i'm just
saying you're on your heart it's easier
on your heart to be fat than that much
that's [ __ ] huge right
because like i said your heart is only
this big yeah you're right yeah
so
it's got to pump everything it's it's in
there like doing its job peter says yeah
my daughter and i bought tickets for
north manor were taken aback at how few
seats were left
full house for an a24 flick very odd
yeah i kind of feel like
it's a masterpiece it's a great i mean
it's really good it's really good i i
really really go down in history man i
liked it a lot well like i said i'm i'm
really into like a 24 in general i
really love robert eggers other stuff
um you know i just admire his like
commitment to the craft uh and what he's
doing and like he's just he doesn't give
a [ __ ] like if people want to see the
[ __ ] or not he's like i'm just going to
make what i want to make right and he's
going to make it like his [ __ ] well
what he wants accurate
he wanted to make conan
yeah but you'll never be able to make
conan because conan
is going to be in the hands of a big
studio and those [ __ ] will never make
it rated r because they're going to
water it down for a general audience and
make it like [ __ ] marvel superheroes
and [ __ ]
when i was a kid i saw [ __ ] conan one
in the [ __ ] theaters it was rated r
and people [ __ ] loved it
it was just as intense
back then as the northman was today it
was just different eras those two movies
can stand side by side the tone is
different the time is different
but the
i would say the the level of of
greatness is the same it's a similar
vibe very similar
the tone is very different though
conan is very
conan is very uh
wagnerian and uh it's a little bit dated
and cartoonish fantasy
yeah this is more
it's still epic but it's more realistic
and it's darker bleaker let's put it in
heavy metal terms
okay
conade would be iron maiden okay
um
the northmen northmen would be [ __ ]
cradle of filth
that's the difference or slayer
like that
a lot harder a lot grittier but still
fantasy it's just
darker yeah more satanic i mean the
northman has fantasy elements and that
there's witches and like people people
going on like spirit walks and [ __ ] like
that yeah but
it's all
it's a lot more grounded in reality it's
not like a frank frazetta painting
necessarily it's a lot more
realistic it's a lot grittier it's a lot
gorier yeah um
so some pretty like [ __ ] up like it's
very violent it's like some real like
realistic violence a little bit more
historically accurate yeah because well
actually they both were accurate
because
conan is trying to trying to tell
howard's
version of [ __ ]
samaria or actually it's not samaria
where is it it's uh what's the name of
the place where he's at
conan was a sumerian but it's a fantasy
world
yeah that conan is in it's not
historical
it's a texans idea of [ __ ] caveman
long time ago back in the days back
it's a caveman back in barbarian days
that it's him telling the story yeah all
right you know [ __ ] old howard and
and howard was
just a big old texan and he was young
trying to come up with a [ __ ] badass
tale
of back back in
back in the old ancient days it could
have anything samurais cavemen
[ __ ] nights well all the bad ass [ __ ]
all the bad ass [ __ ] is in this robot
howard wrote a bunch of stuff he wrote a
bunch of stuff in like weird tales like
a lot of some of his stuff isn't in the
public domain anymore because he has
like an estate that like looks after
that but you can like read a lot of it
online if you care to right not just the
conan story he wrote like a bunch of
others and and howard also put all
continents in the same place you had
zula in there you know i mean you had
black people and white people and
[ __ ] aztec [ __ ] mexican people
they're all in the same vicinity
fighting each other which that's what's
that's the bad ass kind of all the bad
asses and there might yeah a samurai
type dude might show up it's all within
reach of each other and the ancient
egyptians might show up you never could
tell what would happen see that's the
that's the beauty of fiction that was
the beauty of it yeah and then a night
shows up
so you know
i kind of feel like back in the old days
like people were just like yeah whatever
like nowadays if you tried it well i
don't know it's a nowadays journey well
actually those people would not be like
in the same area at the same time
you know maybe i don't know
but it's fiction we're just doing like
fun [ __ ] all the badass [ __ ] in one area
just look at the frank rosetta panty
yeah
frisetta understood
conan [ __ ] well i mean he was
actually hired to paint the
covers of the [ __ ] novels and [ __ ]
you know i mean for signet and all the
company i got it was signet that came up
with all that [ __ ]
so
yeah [ __ ]
that's what that's what howard was
talking about
a fantasy long time ago
although stone
what's his name [ __ ] oliver stone
yeah oliver stone and milius when they
were talk when they were right working
on the script and talking about making
it
they were like
this
fictional past never happened okay
dog-headed men and giant snakes and
[ __ ] monsters
and everybody from every different race
all in the same place and
you know this could never have happened
in the past
maybe this is the future
okay
this is a post-apocalyptic future
where they all all these ancient
cultures have mixed and be and and and
re-arisen out of the ground along with
mutants that had dog-like heads and
mutants that could do [ __ ] psychic
abilities that we call magic and [ __ ]
which is a great idea because after an
apocalypse it's like everybody just has
their own little fragments of
remembered [ __ ] from back in the old
days right yeah so you're not talking
about guns and dragons you're talking
about gamma world all right and that
which would be like fallout you know if
you guys remember gamma world that was
that was the post-apocalyptic version of
dnd
so that's probably that's what howard
that's what that that's what [ __ ]
milius is talking about when he shows
[ __ ] conan it's in the future
and he says so in the opening things
when [ __ ]
conan's dad's telling him about the
[ __ ] gods and how they [ __ ] fell
in fire and lost the riddle of steel on
the battlefield
they talked about the nuclear war in
which they lost
they lost the ability to make steel and
what steel is steel is the will
willpower you know
uh but that's what they're talking about
it's a post-apocalyptic
it's post-about lifting since you
mentioned fallout yeah uh i was gonna
say the uh movie review that i'm putting
up tomorrow
is the 1995 french film city of lost
children yeah which the makers of
fallout have attributed as being the
main influence on the look of the
fallout games particularly fallout 2.
um i don't have you ever seen it city of
lost children
i re-watched it recently like for that
thing and it's like
yeah just i'll put it up tomorrow you'll
see dad says is north men as good as
conan and barbara barrion yeah yeah it
is and i'm a [ __ ] conan the barbarian
john millions fanatic yeah so he says it
then yeah yeah it's badass yeah
it's good and in some ways better
but it is an original creation and it
homages conan one
many times if you're a fan of conan one
you will instantly recognize the order
in which things happen
certain things that he does you go oh
okay yeah but then it happens a little
bit differently okay like the way conan
gets his sword
from the uh
from the [ __ ] atlantean the dead
atlantean king something like that
happens but it's different
um
conan loses sees his dad [ __ ] killed
by wolves
uh has to kind of
loses everything and then kana ends up
in a pit fighting for his life in
another that same kind of thing happens
but it happens a little bit differently
uh conan meets a sorceress who [ __ ]
tells him some [ __ ] then she vanishes in
a ball of fire and runs away something
like that happens but it's bjork this
time
you're going to see you're going to see
it
it will mark with their eyes ripped out
yeah it homages it over and over again
but the tone is different this is not
iron maiden this is celtic frost or
[ __ ] this is [ __ ]
cradle of filth or
this is real
slayer you know it's it's a lot harder
version of that
it's good you'll like it
and it's more accurate it's not fan it
is still fantasy it's got fantasy
aspects yeah cause [ __ ] happened in the
spirit world and they're imagining
things but they're taking drugs too and
they're seeing
you're sometimes shown things
ghosts happen
you just have to see it but no yeah
there's mystical aspects to it but in
the same sense that it would have been
like in real life at the time right you
know what i mean we're just having it in
viking world up in iceland yeah like
we're taking drugs and we're going on
we're going in the sweat lodge or
whatever and we're like going on a
spirit walk right you see like [ __ ] in
that kind of way but the rest of it's
like really realistic but there are
magical weapons
there yeah
there are magical weapons it's like
magical realism yeah
yeah but they really are in iceland okay
this isn't a fictional island that's
real iceland you just got to see it
yeah most of us put that [ __ ] right
next to conan in my in my [ __ ]
collection is it yep that's it they
nailed it that's it
when we were watching the movie i was
like the whole time i was watching like
i was like oh my god this has tom
written all over this movie
yeah this is everything that tom likes
yeah it was almost too much for me to
take in
i want to see it again yeah yeah we can
if you want i don't know yeah
it's almost too much for me too i don't
mind i thought it was awesome yeah
granthar's asking some more questions
these are actually good questions
uh number one name one serial killer you
profiled who you would have over for
dinner
the serial killer that we profiled that
have a um
well okay uh
the iceman
i'd have the i mean he's technically not
well i guess he's technically a serial
killer but he's more like a hit man yeah
i think he'd probably be interesting the
ice man honestly i wouldn't mind this
may be sound [ __ ] up
i wouldn't mind talking to dahmer
is that yeah he'd be easier to handle
because he was kind of that's what i'm
saying i think that because dahmer's
always fascinated me because he always
seemed to me like i'm not excusing what
he did but he always seems to me like
sadder
than most of the other ones i don't know
if you'd call him a serial killer
you maybe you could call him that but uh
general butt naked i mean i would hang
out with general button naked i thought
about environment yeah you and you and
him would get along i thought about it
like we're not having that man over here
it's like can we not yeah would i bring
general butt naked over here take him to
the club
and then he'll cut off some people's
heads with machetes you know he's off
duty he's off dude as military man me
and general butt naked could talk about
it
get recordings and [ __ ] you know and
[ __ ] whole do whole interviews with
me and general butt naked talking
um
a true african warrior
but see you're going more that's like
somebody from conan he was like
something out of conan yeah yeah but
we're talking more like your classical
serial killer a classical serial killer
most of them i just want to choke him me
too like [ __ ] green river killer that
dude he's just a [ __ ] [ __ ] you just
need to be choked well most of them it's
like why you wouldn't want to but like i
said the reason i said dahmer was
because to me
his motivation almost seemed like the
most
the saddest
he didn't come across because a lot of
serial killers like bundy or btk or
somebody like that come across as like
this really like arrogant
um
[Music]
sort of like superior kind of attitude
that they have like they're smarter than
the cops and they you know they're very
like
dehumanizing of their victims
but i feel like dahmer had something
else going on uh he had like a little
bit of a different motivation so like to
me that's like more interesting i still
know if i want him in the house but i'm
just saying
i would feel in less peril from him
yeah oh hold on t was asking about the
reboot of conan with momoa
okay he was not bad in it
but the problem was is that that conan
was
stale uh not real
well
it did not make much of an impression on
me watching it i like jason momoa i
didn't remember much about it i was like
this is really isn't
conan it was just very generic
i wouldn't even [ __ ] with it if you want
to see a good mamoa flit see aquaman i
thought he was great at it was solving
the in the theater i liked aquaman i
mean i like jason momoa generally he
seems like a like a nice dude but um
yeah aquaman was good aquaman was good
that was the closest you're gonna get to
[ __ ] uh flash gordon in the modern
era it was for me it was like watching
the flash gordon flick flash gordon
underwater i like that they kind of like
leaned in to lean into like the
goofiness goofy and [ __ ] but i liked
that about i liked that yeah real good
they didn't they weren't afraid of like
yeah this is cheesy as [ __ ] yeah we're
just gonna do it like that that's why i
want i want a new
flash
and it has to be in that dino de
laurentiis style
goofy as [ __ ] yes sexy with a bunch of
drugs in it because they take drugs even
in the original the old one
there's a lot of sexual innuendo in the
old flash gordon movies
um scantily clad women dripping off the
[ __ ] hands of satanic idols and [ __ ]
over on [ __ ]
you gotta have all that in it
super fun i'm surprised i haven't done
that and you have to have that damn
chinese motif to [ __ ] the people go
well that's a cultural problem man [ __ ]
all that [ __ ] culture
that was the mo that was the motif of
[ __ ] because it was written in a time
when the most exotic thing yeah there's
first you're going to see was a chinese
restaurant
so
yeah that's what they went for you know
what i mean and and that's what [ __ ] i
was getting the 70s and i remember like
chinese food being like super excited
yeah
so that was the motif of that [ __ ]
movie and this is funny but dilaurentis
got it right that's what it was and it
just
it couldn't compete with star wars in
the day i i dug it i got it even back in
the day i saw it like five times in the
theater it's different than star wars
it's a different it's a different tone
it was more
pot smoking 70s hedonistic sexual
star wars was not like that star wars
was very kind of in a way uptight kind
of
kind of reserved star wars trying to be
even though it was like still fantasy it
was a lot more quote unquote realistic
yeah or grounded i guess is a better
word whereas flash gordon like embraced
its over-the-top
craziness goofiness yeah it was just
kind of like yeah we're going like all
the costumes are like super bright
colors with like [ __ ]
glitter on them and [ __ ] they just
wanted to go like glam with this [ __ ]
and i respected that yeah
a lot of people know
the old uh or they know that the
delaurentis flash gordon
basically from seeing it on tv during
the vhs era on the old crt televisions
that didn't really that's not the same
movie
if you saw it in hd or a blu-ray or you
saw it in the theater you saw how
and and you saw it in hd and you saw how
expensive those those uh costumes were
those were beautiful costumes
you don't see that if you see it on vhs
it looks kind of crazy it looks cheesy
looks cheap but not look very expensive
um on on the big screen
but it was uh
hedonistic it was uh [ __ ] decadent
for the day and and but so was the
original source material
[ __ ] think about this [ __ ] you're all
[ __ ]
ming all right
using the power potion before he has
pleasure with his [ __ ]
uh uh [ __ ] slave girls in the damn
what would they call it it is harem all
right
one of the girls that was trying to
constantly make the move on him was his
daughter
he's uh really all right your tastes are
just too dangerous so [ __ ] come on
man and [ __ ] max
that'd be interesting yeah yeah max
spawn seido [ __ ] knocked that [ __ ]
out of the park i don't care if we're
really they were just talking about the
aliens the aliens in the damn movie were
hedonistic yeah
and and that was just like damn
yeah
and [ __ ] you had and in the head of
the secret service
kala
general kala who is me and me and jenny
wanted jenny wanted me
i wanted to do her as a costume one yeah
yeah as gemma carla that'd be badass i
looked into like making it it'd be
expensive but i want to do it one of
these days yeah and [ __ ] what was the
other guy's name i'm just on to my time
it was jim mccalla and [ __ ] um
cleitus cleveland yeah
and he was the head of the secret police
the secret intelligence we were going to
do that like uh yeah
and it's implied and and it's implied
that they're a couple
yeah okay and then they're into bdsm and
they're torturing ming's daughter and
[ __ ]
not the ball of worms yes the boy your
father said we could put the boar worms
on
oh no not the oh wow okay
yeah
because you would be my wife one day
carla's like what you know yeah you know
whatever
whatever
and i was like yeah that was that was uh
dino de la renta studios [ __ ] spent
itself out of damn existence
but it gave us [ __ ] flash gordon and
it gave us dune and it gave us a bunch
of other really good movies the [ __ ] i
was like wait hold on delorentis made
that
and i don't even remember them all now
but they made good movies that were very
underappreciated but they've aged well i
mean flash gordon is super fun yeah i'm
always up for like watching that yeah it
looks beautiful like all the costumes
are beautiful the sets are beautiful
it's just like a fun ass movie real fun
to watch it's a fun ass movie yeah
uh gran there's also asked uh 80s porn
versus modern porn yeah just better and
why modern porn's better more selection
yeah 80s porn it was all same samey
everyone had big hair and tan lines yeah
and it was the same it was the same
performers over and over again pretty
much and then um vhs came in and then he
had a bunch of other girls get involved
and other guys but it was always [ __ ]
ron jeremy [ __ ] the hedgehog and the
same [ __ ] dudes and [ __ ] over and
over again with these [ __ ] california
[ __ ]
bimbos you know
and the uh
the scenes were very generic
same thing over and over again
yeah i kind of feel like until the
internet came along
uh when it was expensive to make porn uh
or at least more expensive than it is
nowadays
you know you only had like uh you know
it was kind of like a hollywood thing
where you had like certain things it was
lower budget obviously but you still had
like kind of bigger studios putting the
porn out because you had to like put it
on vhs or whatever which is expensive
but so like you said you got the same
actors you got like a lot of the same
stuff it was over and over again and
yeah so nowadays you can find like
whatever tiny little niche you're into
you can find a whole world of porn a
whole world of porn that is just like
waiting for you out there for whatever
your very very very specific fetish is
old porn was good for very good-looking
people okay they had some really
good-looking people but the point was
boring it didn't matter
uh the best porn going [ __ ] it's kind
of always been this was like semi pro
and amateur and now you got individual
creators that [ __ ] can come up with
some crazy ass [ __ ] let's drive around
while we blow each other you're going to
give me a hand job behind where we're
driving and [ __ ] they just do crazy
[ __ ] and it's because they're
it's just like youtube you know they
have they have patreons who are paying
them to do this [ __ ] and it's just uh
it's more realistic it's it's hotter
you know what i mean
if the whole thing is a setup
everybody's being paid and [ __ ]
nobody really gives a [ __ ] about each
other and you're in the studio then what
is this you know is it
that's not that hot well i mean i kind
of feel like well okay there is kind of
a thing where
i don't really get
because remember there was like a kind
of
a little bit of a thing
where
we're gonna make porn movies but we're
gonna make them like actual real
like
movies like with 90 minute run times
that have like plots and stuff
um
okay so that was the thing for like 10
minutes
i don't really get that um i don't
really like like the gonzo porn either
honestly i kind of like
if you're just gonna do
i don't know i don't know if i like i i
don't so much like
just gonzo ass porn
but i don't really like porn movies that
are actually trying to be real movies
because those are porn actors and
they're not actor actors
and i would prefer
to me something hotter would be like a
regular movie
that had like a couple of like hot
scenes in it you know what i mean that
would be better porn than a porn movie
trying to be a real movie you know what
i'm saying like don't do that
it just seems like a waste of time you
want another another drink yeah okay
that just seems like a waste of time
honestly some of the hottest [ __ ] i've
seen has been like regular ass movies
that have like hot scenes in them don't
try to make a regular
don't try to make like a porn movie into
a regular movie it just doesn't work if
you're gonna do porn just like do the
[ __ ] porn get it
let's get this going i don't i don't
need to plot you know what i'm saying
uh best way to impress the babes when
you're unfortunate looking
i'll wait until tom comes back to like
weigh in on this but
in my opinion
um
just like i said uh women you would be
surprised are a lot i mean you know i'm
not speaking for all women obviously
women in general let's say that
are a lot more
uh
they're not really as shallow i know
it's terrible to say they're not as
shallow they're not as picky
in terms of looks if
you have something else to offer if you
have something else to offer
meaning
you're funny or you're really sweet or
you're really understanding or you're
into the same [ __ ] as them or something
like that
then it doesn't matter as much what you
look like um i kind of feel like and
again this is a very general statement i
kind of feel like dudes are a little bit
more shallow
in the fact that even if they meet a
girl that's like into the same [ __ ] as
them or is funny or something like that
she still has to be hot or they're not
gonna hit that uh it's not usually the
same the other way around but like i
said it's a very general statement i
know that's not true of everybody
uh women are a lot more forgiving
uh of looks if dudes have something else
going on um you know if you have your
[ __ ] together like i said if you're
super funny or you're
just super like easy to be around or
anything if you have anything going on
especially like i said if you have uh
you know something in common with them
like i said if i met somebody that was
not super you know that wasn't a 10 or
whatever and they were in all the same
horror movies as me and they were like
really nice and all this other kind of
stuff yeah i would totally like [ __ ]
because the thing about women is that
sometimes and again this is very general
women tend to
be a little bit more circumspect um you
know because we have a lot more to lose
uh you can't just go around like [ __ ]
any rando
uh so we have a lot more to lose
generally
so we're a lot more like discerning
um so the thing about it is that
you meet somebody
that is maybe not the best looking but
the more you get to know them
like the more you like spending time
with them the more attractive they will
seem to you you know what i mean whereas
i think dudes are like the other way
around
i think dudes a lot of times will like
see a hot chick and be like i don't even
care what that [ __ ] is like i'm just
going to hang out with that that chick
until i get sick of her
that's what i mean so they'll be a lot
more forgiving of women if if women are
hot
then they'll be a lot more forgiving of
that woman being crazy or annoying or
whatever
just because she's hot you know what i
mean whereas women are kind of like
generally or
opposite um women will usually be like
well you know this guy's cool like he's
not
i don't i've never thought this but
maybe some women do it's like oh he's
not that great looking but blah blah
blah
um
but the more you hang out with them it's
like man we have so much in common and
he's like he's so nice to me he's like
so interested in stuff like that and
that person will become more attractive
to you the more that you have in common
with them and the like the closer you
get with them so i kind of feel like
women
are more
it's more like a long time thing like
the more they get to know you
the more attractive
you are to them you know what i'm saying
and that's a very general i know like
not all women are like that but i kind
of feel like dudes are like the opposite
you know
because we're designed differently
that's what i'm saying because honestly
like i used to know like i said i have a
lot of male friends and i did like going
back
when i was a teenager
and dudes will put up with
ridiculous amounts of stuff
from chicks if they're hot depends on
how old ridiculous depends on their age
and then they'll [ __ ] to me about it my
geeky yes depends on that and i'm like
and why are you why are you having sex
with her if she annoys you so much but
she's hot though
it
well what worked with men
males of all [ __ ] species over time
is to get as many women pregnant as
possible well yeah yeah and they're not
talking about you know and this is
beyond this goes
not just the human species all species
it's just that's the way the male gender
worked
so
male primates are similar to that just
get them pregnant first
because you'll have offspring
a lot of your ancestors were born that
way that's why you have that
now but for long-term relationships
if you want to raise children
you have to be able to tolerate the the
the the female at least because you're
gonna have to be male if you sound like
a ferengi well no it might be
well no because i'm not just talking
about humans yeah all right i'm talking
about i know i'm just teasing talking
about in other species too
because you know
animals of other species will sometimes
just
basically kind of just [ __ ] attack
and rape
yeah the female species they're like hey
i don't have to raise it by saying the
raven is luke but then that same [ __ ]
animal might [ __ ] actually
kind of mate and impregnate
the female of its own species and then
stay with it
that happens also
in animals yeah well it depends on the
species you can't really i mean you
can't really generalize across the whole
animal kingdom because it's all it's all
over the map right it's all over the map
i know that like some like people that
are into like evolutionary psychology
which by the way is a lot of [ __ ]
um it is just kind of like oh well we
see this in these
so it's like obviously males want to do
this on the other but that's not how it
works in every single species it's kind
of like all over the map so you it's a
lot more negative it's what works what
works is like i said it's a lot more
nuanced than uh
than people would have you believe
depending animals are still animals
well yeah but so are we yeah but i'm
just saying there's a very very broad
spectrum in uh the way that the way that
different animals like go about
their mating strategies yeah you're just
a product of your ancestry though
mating strategies are
wildly divergent and it's on sometimes
in the same species yeah it can be on a
spectrum right
it's like look
because there's competition not only
between species there's competition
within a species
okay
usually what ends up rising to the top
is an alpha male he's got access to a
bunch of females he protects them he
gets most of them pregnant or all of
them that he can get pregnant he gets
pregnant
but there's another kind of male who's
kind of like the [ __ ] prince or the
[ __ ] you know i mean he's kind of the
grass aisle [ __ ] who
he's not an alpha male all right
but the females like him and [ __ ] he
gets them pregnant too and the alpha
male [ __ ] raises them thinking that
they're his that happens in a lot of
species
but that's where those guys that's where
those kind of males are coming from
because their ancestry has that in them
it's almost kind of like a parasite but
not really
because
that's what the ladies like them yeah
that male is offering something
it's like you know it's just yeah we
have like the dude that is kind of dumb
but can like beat everyone's ass but
also he's providing security and we have
this guy's entertaining that's like
super funny yeah super cute and he list
actually listens to me when i talk and
doesn't like you know
animals can't talk no you know what i'm
saying right but you know the the
but that well actually animals can't
talk thank you i know yeah
but that that happens in and that
happens also there there's more than one
things are being selected at once
so that's what i mean
so as i said it's a lot more like uh
complicated right than uh then people
would
entertain so
anybody that comes out with just like oh
well men are like this and women are
like that
no uh no that's that's not how it works
it's a lot in every species there's
about four or five different kinds of
males and about three or four different
kinds of there's a lot of different [ __ ]
you can do a lot of different strategies
a lot of different strategies uh tila
says have a good sense of humor and be
down to earth and love yourself i think
those are the those are probably like
the three best things i've ever heard
yeah
yeah have a good sense of humor don't be
um you know don't be that kind of
[ __ ] that like people make jokes
and [ __ ] like that and you're
uh you take the [ __ ] too seriously don't
be like that
uh be kind of self-deprecating i kind of
like that um you know don't get too up
yourself where you can't take a joke
about yourself or something like that
yeah down to earth i don't really like
people that are
too up themselves like i said um i like
people that are kind of like genuine
honest
[ __ ] like that um
and confidence uh this is probably the
thing that i have the most trouble with
but
yeah
[Music]
confidence goes a long way to be honest
with you um that might be
i don't know that might be the most
important
thing
really well that's your delivery right
there
that's what i'm saying like no matter
what you have going on like because
everybody has something or you know more
than once more most people have more
than one something um what you should do
is find out what those somethings are
and play to those strengths right and if
you do that um and don't apologize for
it
and just like this is me and like you
know [ __ ] it
that i mean unless you're terrible uh
you know that's a whole other thing
but
if you're confident and you project that
then people will respond to that
yeah and you also can't get hung up in
stereotypes like i was like earlier on i
gave a very [ __ ]
simplistic view of [ __ ] an alpha male
doing this and that and then another guy
who's kind of like a sigma who comes in
and [ __ ]
is getting the [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ]
and he's raising
their alpha there are alpha guys out
there that are [ __ ] big and strong
but also have [ __ ] good sense of
humor and real intelligent and [ __ ]
kind of like superman they got those too
you know i mean just because the
[ __ ] is big and strong and he's
an alpha doesn't mean he's dumb
it's just uh there are a lot of big dumb
[ __ ] like that but they're not
all like that
yeah you can't
you can't just like assume right
anything about anybody really i mean
probably you shouldn't i mean you could
say uh neil degrasse tyson would have
been one of those when he was young he
was a big strong alpha type guy but he
was a [ __ ] scientist too
i had magical yeah he was an athlete he
was an idiot yeah right he was just
[ __ ] wrestler and [ __ ] he was also
so you know i mean you can't
why do you think so many women love neil
degrasse tyson for christ's sake
yeah well you kind of have that dude is
like that is one sexy [ __ ] right
there well imagine when he was young he
was [ __ ] in real good shape and [ __ ]
you know what i mean it [ __ ] would
have been you know even even more so
impactful you know he's a little older
now you know and [ __ ] yeah but even
kids and gaining weight yeah but like
i'm reading his books and i'm like
having like a little bit of an orgasm
i'm just having a little bit of a nerd
guessing we were talking carl's
right he's like like a carl sagan your
brain turns me on right i mean i'm into
that i mean
it'd be the same thing [ __ ] they had
women they just [ __ ] loved carl sagan
tyson was like sagging but [ __ ]
[ __ ] was big and strong you know
what i mean it's just he was good
looking guy you know when he was in good
shape and seeing pictures of me like
yeah
yeah
it's like muffin could be popular yeah
neil degrasse tyson is awesome because
well
the reason why uh people like neil
degrasse tyson and carl sagan like got
so popular is because there's a popular
perception
and maybe there's some
something behind this but there's a
popular perception that people that are
really really good at the sciences or
math or something like that are usually
like nerds or they're not really good
socially
so if you have somebody like carl sagan
or like neil degrasse tyson who is like
a super super good scientist but also is
like really socially adept and like kind
of confident and sexy and is really good
at like communicating to the public
that seems to be i don't know if it's
really true or not but you know public
perception would be that that's like a
very unusual combination to come along
like oh my god it's a sexy nerd
and i think you know people don't really
have that um
stigma as much nowadays but they used to
tease off to see um [ __ ] uh the
doctor dr strange you have a good night
tea have a good one honestly everybody
said it was good they were coming
everybody that was coming out of the
theater we were waiting to go in to see
the north man everybody was coming out
and we saw some people like doing live
streams like about like coming out oh my
god this is the best i liked it better
than spiderman i liked it they were like
super into it so you know
i didn't even see the first one
although it looks cool but
superhero movies are good but it's like
they're never my number one go-to
you know i like them but they're
i don't know it's like it's hard to say
i like them i like them but they're not
like
asking about who's attractive who's more
attractive [ __ ] neil degrasse tyson
anthony bourdain or [ __ ] imaginable
connie i'd say [ __ ]
[ __ ] um
neil degrasse tyson [ __ ] when he was
in it yeah good shape anthony bourdain's
kind of hot too i mean he's dead now but
you know when he was alive but yeah
matthew mcconaughey i'm not
he's
good looking but it's like he's kind of
more like his persona i don't vibe with
the persona he's more he's more like a
beach bum
kind of like pot smoking kind of thing
which you know that's fine if that's
your thing but it's like not really my
thing see neil
tyson's gonna come at a woman like this
okay he's gonna
he's gonna take her out to the lake
underneath the stars at night okay we're
gonna go to the observatory
go to the observatory he's going to tell
me about all the constellations he's
going to lay out a blanket with some
pillows they have a picnic basket at
night and we're going to talk about the
stars see how i'm into that he's going
to walk a woman through the whole story
and this and that and he's going to have
good stories about the [ __ ] and then
he's gonna
talk about the nebula and how you know
nebula nebulae and he's gonna talk about
the different layers inside jupiter and
[ __ ] he's gonna go all that [ __ ] and
those women are gonna be like they're
gonna be loving that [ __ ] yeah
that's
he's going to have a whole [ __ ]
tour through the skies to the stars and
then it's going to end with him getting
blown you know it's gonna happen but
well yeah but how's the woman gonna
resist
you know what i certainly would they're
just gonna be crawling across the
motherfucker's lap and [ __ ] [ __ ]
looking at the stars
big old big old
i ain't gonna say anything anymore
that's it we didn't get demonetized
we've already put it well the whole
channel hasn't been demonetized but a
lot of our videos do get demonetized
right right they don't get well yes
honestly most of the videos they get
demonetized are like the true crime
stuff which like i said they they
usually do they don't get demonetized
it's just that they don't show like
certain cover they only show like adult
commercials or we're not going to be
commercials because it's true crime
because we're talking about photoshop
uh grampar says tom is a volcano of
confidence ninety percent of it
warranted
whoa ninety percent of it the only
ninety that's that's generous
[Laughter]
i told you
he's known me forever and i don't think
he understands like how see how she is
how part of my nature smart [ __ ] is
i grew up
my i mean my dad my grandparents
everything like that were smart asses
yeah that's just like my my main way of
communicating yeah you know what i mean
i don't mean to be offensive or anything
like that it's just that's just like the
first thing that comes out of my mouth
yeah
it's smart answer
and he will say we're in the dawn of the
age of aquarius yeah that's right
look at
degrasse tyson neil tyson
i have a bunch of his books over there
on my channel
i love that he got so passionate about
the whole pluto thing right everybody
got mad at him
about him wanting to demote pluto right
i mean it wasn't just him obviously he
was just yeah it was well they were just
kind of like well look if pluto is a
planet then like all these other extra
planetary like things out here are also
planets because they're all the same
size and neil was just like popularizing
that and he wrote a book about how he
got like death threats yeah he got death
threats for people that were like how
dare you not make pluto a planet and
blah blah blah and he's like [ __ ] i
didn't do that a lot of pop a lot of pop
scientists
or pop astronomers or whatever
cosmologists they catch a lot of flack
from their own community like oh well
he's no smarter than me and this there's
a lot of player hate
yeah there is yeah in in the scientific
community
um
but let me tell you something is neil
degrasse tyson better
than [ __ ] other people in in
amongst cosmologists no but that's not
what this is about okay they're they're
a group of guys working on problems each
one has their own problems uh you know
that they're trying to solve in in in
their field
what tyson is about is that
and also the same thing as [ __ ] carl
sagan
they could communicate to the mass
audience yeah and make uh their field
seem very interesting which is a
different talent a totally different
skill sure
you know and not everybody has that
especially not in the scientific
community most of those people are this
this be obvious
let's be honest uh kind of painfully
nerdy and not real good in front of
crowds
uh they tend to be kind of shy
um
social skills not really there
but
not sagan and [ __ ] tyson you know
those [ __ ] could
get in front of an audience of people
of all different walks of life and win
them over and that's what science needs
you have to have that yeah i kind of
feel like you do need yeah you need like
people that are like really good at the
[ __ ] science obviously but you gotta
have the community you also need people
that are maybe you know maybe they're
not like the best at the science but
they had the star power but they also
have the ability the charisma
to actually like communicate that to the
public in a way that the public can
understand right i've said it before
earlier on the show maya lois who was in
the mad mountain poltergeist book that
jenny wrote
worked for
worked at palomar observatory
and um she was uh secretary to one of
the guys there i
forgot
penner dr penner was his name i i
believe
and uh carl sagan would show up all the
time back in the 80s when she worked
there
and
lois said that carl sagan was the
sexiest man she had ever seen
i could say that
she
huge star power i mean there was just
something about him
he's just very charismatic he said that
[ __ ] he he would [ __ ] walk in and
talk and play and then he would leave
and women in the room
would just go
after he was gone
and she said that there was a lot of
tension in the room when he showed up it
was like because it was
like being in the presence of
the superstar and like and it was it was
sexual for women
you know i could say i understand as i
said understand it women's sexuality in
general i know everybody's not like that
but women's sexuality is a lot more tied
into
status and well no like there's now the
way you make us feel right um and a lot
of that has to do depending on what the
woman is like if you're really into like
intellectual kind of [ __ ] like if some
dude comes in
like with all the science [ __ ] and also
has like all this
you know animal magnetism and all this
charisma that's going to be like [ __ ]
catnip yeah right there and you look at
him and he's not an ugly guy but he's
not what i would think would be a woman
would be a sex symbol but evidently he
was oh yeah and i could see that that
that is not mysterious to me whatsoever
it might be mysterious to dudes it is
not dude
it is not mysterious to me i can kind of
understand it but he was um
and according to lois uh he was uh hard
to get
that you know what i mean like
well yeah she probably had more
important things to do
he had girlfriends well yeah but he was
like very hard to get yeah you know
i'm carl [ __ ] thank you yeah he's
carl [ __ ]
you gotta be better than that right but
yeah but
you know like i said emily was [ __ ]
dating
hotties
like i said we're talking about hotties
real hotties we'll see and and they were
smart yeah
so you know it's kind of hard for me to
say like i said because
to me
my whole like concept of sexiness
doesn't have anything necessarily
to do with what people look like yeah
it's all
it's a whole gestalt thing like you have
to have a whole thing going on
it doesn't really matter like what you
look like necessarily yeah but the thing
is those i would say carl sagan was good
looking he is good looking but he was
not a fat guy or anything like that he
was right but smaller slender guy
and uh i would say he was good looking
in the way that spock or leonard namoy
was good looking kind of like that you
guys know how i feel about it you know i
mean
you're not talking about a real muscular
guy not real macho
not in the [ __ ] traditional warrior
sense of the way but a scholar
scholar machismo he had that
yeah see and i'm kind of like i'm into
that though right i'm into that though i
like that kind of and as i said he never
came across i mean he was very
he never he always came across as like
he was very intelligent but he didn't
come he he was intelligent but not
condescending it wasn't arrogant jason
or arrogant yeah lois city wasn't
arrogant um
like i said like intelligent is good
arrogance not so much right i don't like
arrogant i don't like condescending i
don't like anything like that i do like
smart
but if you're the kind of smart where
you're lording it over everybody yeah
that's very unattractive
um but if you're smart and you're like
kind of like interested in stuff and
you're passionate about stuff and
you know and you can hang with like
regular people without like
trying to like pull rank by feeling like
superior you know what i mean what read
what grandparents said about steve
steve is was my best friend in high
school after talking about it
our friend steve made the panties drop
by talking to the girls about old school
pink floyd astrophysics genetic
engineering chemistry apex biology and a
bunch of other intellectual stuff yeah
well see um had i been around at that
time period that you had a jesus complex
that would have worked on me too
probably back in those old days
back back went back because that's like
the whole contents of my bookshelf you
don't even know
back when steve back when steve
backs back when steve was in high school
though he had almost a messiah
accomplished that women thought that he
could have been a [ __ ] great cult
leader
because those young high school girls
actually just thought he was like the
messiah okay well that's a little bit
it's just [ __ ] yeah he was like the
second like that he was he could do no
wrong
uh
which he could don't get dick dazzled
girls oh they were getting dick dazzled
seriously they were getting [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] steve was a master does it
but they were they were good girls
though they were good they were dildos
these were yeah no he was not bad too
what are we talking about no no i'm just
saying you're not going to let a girl
get some dick no they're getting [ __ ]
from it no yeah i'm not saying that i'm
just saying no what i was saying is he
was awesome steve was awesome
i'm just saying in general yeah i'm
talking of young girls i'm not talking
about steve particularly i'm talking
about young girls in general
don't get dick dazzled in the sense that
you think this dude has like the best
dick ever and so like that's
yeah i'm going to give it some advice to
you young women go ahead and get dick
dazzled sometimes you got a [ __ ]
out there that is dazzling you with a
dick and yeah that might be the best
thing you're ever going to have
you just don't know what's going to
happen just have fun
have fun
don't let jenny tell you not to jump on
a dick no i didn't jump on a date that's
not what i said i didn't say not to jump
on the dick okay
dick dazzle
means that
the dick is so good that you will
forgive
yeah all of the bad [ __ ] that the dude
does depending on the dude though that's
the end that is the experience though of
it i'm just saying women they some women
have to have that experience you know
i'm talking about that that just i feel
like all women have had that experience
let it happen and most but i'm just
saying i'm just saying
don't get so caught up
in yeah it's the most awesome dick it
look look i get it i get it
but don't get so caught up in that that
you'll forgive
anything that the person attached to
that dick does
because i kind of that's what i mean by
dick jackson on the show great i'm going
to get steve on the show and i'm not
talking about steve i'm just talking in
general
because sometimes steve would talk you
right out in pants
i'll be bringing steve on i doubt that
and i'll [ __ ] i'm old
i said steve i'm old now and i'm cranky
i said do me a favor talk around in
pants and [ __ ] steve steven put put
the number on you even to this day no he
wouldn't i talked to him all the time
either
well you know it would happen slow it
would be over a period of
no okay i'm not gonna i'm not gonna play
with you that way but okay
i'm too cranky for that [ __ ] she's
cranky i'm old and cranky that shit's
not gonna happen
i don't [ __ ] with that steve was steve
was [ __ ] the next one actually i
didn't like fall for that crap back in
the old days you would have fallen after
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you would have fallen
maybe when i was like 16 or 17 i would
have fallen yeah i probably would have
fallen for it when i was 16 or 17. but
once i got into like my 30s no [ __ ]
way
no way and like i said nowadays way too
old she doesn't understand back in the
day oh i understand back in the day oh i
understand you would have so much
[ __ ] fun it was fun
it was a lot of fun because well i had
fun too yeah i'm just saying i had fun
we weren't we didn't make any promises
you know
me me and steve were
[ __ ] hanging out and [ __ ] having
fun and [ __ ] making friends with all
these girls and [ __ ] [ __ ] was
happening
and
but nobody ever lied we never lied to
any of those girls
it was just fun they were friends you
know
it's not everybody knew that they were
having fun too everybody knew nobody was
getting married we were going to
graduate in a couple years and be gone
you know it was the high school time
although high school for me might have
been different for it was for you i
don't know but
no i'm just saying i'm
look i'm not saying that right
what i meant i think you like took it
way too seriously
and you you got like sensitive about it
yeah i've gotten sensitive about this
[ __ ] you did yeah when i say don't get
dick dazzled i said
don't
like look even if the dick is good like
for the girls yeah even if the dick is
good when you're young
um
don't let that like overshadow like if
the dude does like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
otherwise yeah that's all i'm saying
like don't let that like blind you to
their other behavior that's all i'm
saying because that's something that
happens let
you young girls
please don't young age please let me
speak to you here's a friend
a 50 odd year old man from the
experience okay who has never been a
woman
trying to give advice but not from
experience let's hear it from i'm very
very interested in how this is gonna go
don't be afraid of the dick dazzling and
don't [ __ ] don't don't think that it's
that that it's a
don't don't think that it's anything
kind of [ __ ] insidious because most
of the time the dude that's doing it
he's fallen for it too he really means
what he's saying at the time at the time
rapidly when you're young they do yeah
and and you're young and you're kind of
dumb and [ __ ] happens and you and you're
with one and then another one comes up
and you can't really tell just in tune
yeah okay and then you can't yeah it's
like a woman's heart will get broken but
that's just the way it is when you're
young and you're dumb and it doesn't
have anything but but the whole but that
whole experience
is kind of what
makes life
that's the learning experience well if
anything i kind of feel like by
implication that's kind of what i was
saying yeah um because women in general
like i said not all of them but they
will tend to get like kind of fixated
yeah on one dude
and what i'm saying is don't get fixated
on one dude just because he has like the
magical dick or whatever because that
dude might be like horrible in other
ways even though he's like really good
at one thing it's not the difference
thank you may i may i speak go ahead
while i go to the restroom you go ahead
and talk now go ahead go [ __ ] with you
thank you
all i'm saying is that
i kind of feel like girls particularly
younger girls
uh they tend to get really fixated on
one particular dude and i'm just saying
don't do that right okay um i'm just
saying that
you know you get like all fixed like
this dude's like really
you know like really really good at one
particular thing
and so you'll forgive like all the other
shitty things he does
please don't do that like pl please play
the field please play somebody they'll
get find somebody that like is
is just good for you in other ways
you can you know and experiment with
lots of different things
i'm going to say this dick dazzling
which i think is a genius phrase made by
jenny i just made that i did like it i
do like it it is i might have i might
have read it somewhere it is i don't
remember it it is sexist against males
but i'm gonna go ahead and go okay with
that [ __ ]
dick dazzling is kind of like
it is kind of like what it was but i'm
gonna [ __ ] put this [ __ ] down and lay
it down it had nothing to do with the
dick and it really wasn't any much to do
with sex it was mostly what we were
doing and saying how we were making
everybody feel how you make the woman
feel that's good it's it was the it was
it didn't it wasn't dick or sex it was
everything else
okay
and
and we weren't doing that for the sex
the sex would just kind of come it would
kind of come naturally because we were
having so much fun that's part of what
it was but see that's the way it should
be that's what it was that's how good it
was that's what that's what it should be
so
that's why i'm telling these girls no if
if you get into those situations you
just roll with it just know that you're
young everything's temporary when you're
young and the dudes that are doing this
if they're good
they don't mean any harm
they just don't understand how life is
at that time because the guys are just
as dumb as the girls dumber dumber they
are dumber dumber in some ways
the girls were ahead of us yeah
the girls that [ __ ] were our friends
and all this [ __ ] was going down
grabbers knows who they are
second um
we weren't putting anything over on them
you know what i mean they they hung out
with us willingly we were all friends
they would start fighting though
because
there'd be more than two there'd be four
or five of them you know um and i guess
you know me and
me and steve ran neck and neck
but he was more popular than me
we had two very different styles
similar but very real different
we were both successful he was a little
bit more successful than me i think
though at it
but it didn't matter we weren't
competing it was just
we were both we were both successful
dudes we were having fun you know
boy boy looking back at that [ __ ] but it
was it was it was
well i mean it was a time of raw
animal magnetism as long as you're not
doing anything malicious no nothing or
against anyone's
will no
then
grandparents can attest granters can
attest we couldn't keep them away from
us
we couldn't like right i get that
they would just start showing up
i'm just saying like i said i wasn't
making i i kind of feel like you jumped
to a thing where you were like thinking
i was impugning like okay no no i wasn't
i was just saying like in general
uh teenage girls have a thing where it's
like oh i found this one dude and he's
like amazing in bed or whatever and it's
like you'll forgive everything else that
he does just because of that
i was like please don't fall into that
trap that's what i was saying we were in
the drama program putting on shows and
we had our own thing going and it just
was like a magnet it would just attract
them
and we'll see probably being like the
drama club
i kind of feel like that and because you
were obviously dudes that were very one
very confident yeah too confident enough
to be in the drama club
back in those days yeah it was singing
live in front of back in those days i
kind of feel like the jock kind of
contingent be like oh that's okay
no no a lot of we had a lot of jock
france i know i'm just saying like
in general i kind of feel like that was
sort of the zeitgeist no we got a lot of
respect as soon as we got a lot of
respect girls love that [ __ ] we got a
lot of respect from the jocks because we
were doing things that would scare them
they'd get scared to get up and sing
they play in front it's easy you know
they do their [ __ ]
hockey and [ __ ] remember how good eric
was with the [ __ ] hockey [ __ ]
hockey and football they had their own
things going but they weren't singing
in front of a live audience or doing you
know what i mean so now we got we got
respect for them soon as they saw us
live doing [ __ ] we got all kinds of
respect
it's just enough because that's
something that a lot of people even like
macho dudes that are like athletes
you're performing in front of a [ __ ]
won't do well they're performing it's
the same thing yeah you're performing in
front of a [ __ ] crowd it's just that
that's another hard thing that you do
in front of a and honestly i kind of
feel like doing [ __ ] like singing or
drama or something something like that
that's honestly more
you're making yourself more vulnerable
yeah this is just me right and i'm
singing and it's like so we were singing
without amplifiers just like i said
so a lot of jocks like you said yeah
they'll go out and play football or
basketball or whatever but they wouldn't
do that yeah so to me i kind of feel
like that's more
manly
than
[Music]
it's different it's different but to me
that's more because you're willing to
say hey [ __ ] it i'm going to get out
there and say i don't give a [ __ ] right
you know
he was in drama with us too all right
[ __ ] it's the same thing you're on a
team some people though are [ __ ]
quarterbacks and some people are [ __ ]
linebackers and it's just
you're out there singing solos live in
front of an audience
a [ __ ] high school [ __ ]
quarterback
is gonna go yeah that's rough [ __ ]
that's kind of like what i do
it's just different you know what i mean
but yeah it's the same thing it's the
same thing right yeah
you're performing and right that's right
pro sports and hollywood there's
it's both entertainment it's it's
similar
similar similar deal
grampher says uh jenny is a wise sage
who speaks great truths
hopefully you're not just being
sarcastic
[ __ ] and granthars also says
granters was jealous he didn't have the
same mojo or big dick energy
fake take energy
i didn't land any of the leads man
you didn't land any of the leads you
could have
you just have to [ __ ] like i said
it's energy
you gotta honestly it's and this is one
of the things and you know and i can
relate because i i kind of have this
whole i'm not a dude but like i have
this whole kind of thing going on too
but
confidence has a lot to do with it goes
really far and it's taken me like until
i was probably like almost 40 years old
to like figure that out
um
yeah when i met jenny she didn't have
much as much confidence
i fostered a lot of i had zero
yeah i fostered a lot of confidence in
jenny but it's like because i had
experience with i still don't have a lot
you do you know you have a lot i mean i
have it's better than it was i will say
that it's it because what i understood
it though because i was in the same
position a long time ago
nobody pushed you
all right
but i'll tell you what after a few books
and then going to [ __ ] signings and
dealing with the public it comes quick
you already had a taste of it it's it's
real what we were doing at what what me
and you were doing at the uh
at the uh
those big conventions and [ __ ] is real
similar
to what you know what i mean uh what we
were doing on stage back in high school
similar i mean i did [ __ ] in the pub
like i sang in uh you know in chorus
for a long time
um
later i like when i was in high school
uh my choir director asked me if i would
please like do a solo thing for
you know the big uh competition
and i absolutely
would not because i was terrified i
would not say i don't mind like seeing
but honestly i was like pretty nervous
about singing with other people singing
but
i would absolutely i was terrified like
to sing by myself i was like there is no
way i was like i would get up there at
the competition and i was just like i
wouldn't even like my throat would dry
up and i wouldn't even be able to do it
so i was like absolutely not i can't do
that he did ask me but i was like no i
can't
and
i don't know i kind of look back on that
it's like i kind of wish i would have
because back in the old days like i
really liked to sing and i thought i
could sing really well but
i'd sing in my house
but i didn't really want anybody else to
hear me
you know what i mean so it's kind of
like
i don't know i guess i was all right but
i don't know i just never i just never
thought i was like good enough so
i don't know it's it's a [ __ ] man it's
a [ __ ] and i've had that like my whole
[ __ ] life
so i mean tom helped because he was so
confident
because honestly like i don't know if
you guys know but i was married before
for 15 years actually
and um you know i don't have any ill
will against my ex-husband and but he
was a lot more similar to me
in the sense that he was very
shy and very introverted and stuff like
that so i kind of feel like i was a lot
more comfortable around him because he
was a lot more similar to me but it
didn't really like push me out of my
comfort zone in any way you know what i
mean
um so i kind of feel like i was
attracted to tom initially because he
was so opposite to me because he was so
outgoing and he was and i was really not
like that i'm still not like that uh to
be honest with you
but
he just kind of like pushed me into
doing [ __ ] because honestly my whole
entire life and i don't know why i feel
like this because my parents didn't do
this to me or anything like that but my
whole entire life i've kind of felt like
i had to like apologize for my existence
like why like i'm here and it's like oh
hey here i did a thing
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like
if you want to look at it you can't but
bye you know what i mean it's just i
don't know and i shouldn't feel like
that but
i don't know i still kind of do
it's better than it was but
you know you know you were there yeah
graham i want you to uh
before i forget hit me up on messenger i
want to talk to you afterwards
grantham's also said uh funny thing the
band and drama girls were way hornier
than the cheerleaders yes
oh yeah big time yeah and in a way they
were cuter
a lot a lot of the a lot of the [ __ ]
a lot of the a lot of the cheerleaders
were
pretty
but they just weren't
they weren't very attractive the
exception i always liked jody spears i
still [ __ ] have contact with jody
jody was cute
a little short girl from texas i liked
her she was cute
um but a lot of them were just kind of
generic you know
generic
not to say anything bad about
cheerleaders i'm sure they're [ __ ]
certain areas they're good yeah and the
thing about it well you don't know until
you know that person right yeah but i
kind of feel like that's
kind of carried over to nowadays and now
like what i say about
actors and stuff like that that are
movies that are you know classically
handsome and stuff i'm like well
they don't seem that interesting to me
yeah
i'm kind of more
if i'm gonna be like attracted to
somebody
even if they're like weird looking it's
gonna be somebody that's like
interesting yeah somebody that's just
like blandly good looking and that's it
jody was jody was cute because she was
like a shapely little short muscular
texican girl which is you know kind of
like anglo mexican kind of
girl and she was uh
just ki and her brother was a real thug
[ __ ] uh
yeah and there was just there was some
something about her and she was sweet
she worked at mcdonald's when part-time
when she was a junior and oh my god my
brother used to work yeah
yeah i liked her
um in terms of in terms of [ __ ] um
uh
uh of cheerleaders she came over the
house one time me and her we're making
out
and she's cute man i was and then i
don't know what happened i didn't hook
up with her i got distracted or
something
that's the way it was distracted it was
the way it was for me back in those days
wait there's grabbers can [ __ ] attest
there'd be one of them and then another
one would [ __ ] block her
you know time about and try to they were
fighting each other
over me steve and that out of the drama
club that was it me and steve they were
fighting over us
because we
[Music]
it was ridiculous looking back on it it
was ridiculous it was ridiculous looking
back on it but no the girls were
fighting over us
[Laughter]
and we weren't doing it they were doing
it
yeah i mean we weren't responsible
we were being played i think
yeah you probably were it probably were
yeah anyway yeah
yeah gramsci also says i'm not being
sarcastic jenny your smarts and wisdom
are a million dollar trades thank you
very much i appreciate that a lot i
appreciate that
uh yeah grant said her brother was a
thug jeff was his name
i was going to court for something he
died 10 years ago yeah well he tried to
kill himself back in high school
remember when he tried to drink all that
damn brake fluid
what yeah
tried to kill himself he got a way to
kill yourself got pissed off one time
went in the garage and opened up the
thing of [ __ ] brake fluid and drank
it
man i've been pretty pissed off i don't
think i've ever been there yet it sent
him to the hospital he was a thug what
was funny is that he was trying to be a
nice guy
he was mean
and uh well at least he was trying yeah
and then he tried to kill himself
and then i saw him later
and i said you all right man [ __ ] i
heard about what happened he said yeah
thank you for to thank you he says i
tried to kill myself this is why you're
trying to kill yourself i said this and
it says do what
and he's like man life isn't good and i
said
and he goes nobody likes me
and this is and i said well
he says dude you're [ __ ]
you know you kind of threaten other
people man just be cool man come hang
out with us
he's like oh thank you
i don't know if you know about that
graham but [ __ ] i invited him to come
hang out with us
he was being rejected i guess and which
is making him more and more thuggish
i kind of feel like that happens a lot
in this situation well yeah but he never
he never showed up yeah he says come
hang out with us man
[ __ ] but see i get that like okay
like i'm an introvert so it's it's kind
of a thing where it's like people want
you to like come and hang out with them
yeah but you don't really want to
because it's really stressful right and
then when you don't people think that
you're
snotty or standoffish or something like
that so everybody will like have a
projection of you that maybe isn't
entirely true yeah and so then like
everybody stops inviting you to stuff
because they think you're a snot but
it's like you're not showing up and
stuff not because you're a snot but
because you think nobody wants you there
yeah well that's kind of the way he was
he thought nobody liked him
and everybody thought he i get that i
guess he thought nobody liked him but
everybody actually thought he was gonna
whip your ass
yeah you know what i mean he was
intimidating to be around yeah and i
invited him over says no man come on
hang out with us man it'll be all right
man it's gonna be okay
and [ __ ] you so yeah yeah thank you man
i'm gonna come hang out with you guys
but he never showed up
i said well what was smoking see it
might have been yeah like i said because
people like that like
like i said i know because i think like
this too it's like look nobody wants me
there yeah nobody wants to hang out with
me
you knew who else was like that they're
just saying that to me who else wanted
to hang out with me and mike kowalski
and that [ __ ] used to try to
bully us and [ __ ] he act like
john
john
who is that big [ __ ] with the
damn [ __ ] mustache and [ __ ] would
always try to [ __ ] beat a
motherfucker's ass john
had that [ __ ]
brown mullet gotta pee
he was a dick man he was a dick nobody
liked him he was a [ __ ] bully
but
i tried to get him to come hang out with
us too
and he turned he turned over a new leaf
he stopped being an [ __ ]
you know who he is graham
and grandpa says yeah that dude was a
mess man super smart but very so yeah
that's right yeah
his name was no not john casey what the
[ __ ] is somebody his name was not john
[ __ ] what's his name
swears no no not swear john
he had a little [ __ ] mustache and a
[ __ ] you know how those stupid ass
mullets he was big man he was probably
like six feet tall
and
uh
he was he seemed to be [ __ ] well
built for this for high school he's kind
of do the walk up and [ __ ] smack in the
back of the head
you're like what the [ __ ]
you always wanting to fight
and then people kind of rejected him and
then all of a sudden he's like no i'm
not like that anymore i'm not like that
he started to get kind of cooler
but i forgot his name
yeah you hung with pat that's right
because i didn't tell me how pat yeah
that guy that guy i forgot his name
i don't know what happened to that guy
john
i think he turned over a new leaf though
because that [ __ ] tried to beat
everybody's asses and then he had no
friends
but uh
it's funny like [ __ ] eventually the
way he got it's [ __ ] me and mike
kowalski and they'd try to pick on mike
all the time you know because mike was a
little skinny looking little
[ __ ] bug-eyed
but i liked mike mike was [ __ ] great
he's [ __ ] funny
he'd walk by and we'd like hey what's up
man what's up and [ __ ] and he would
act like he was just like he was a
[ __ ] politician and [ __ ] where and
he'd walk off of me and mike are like
man about a year ago that [ __ ]
was trying to whip our asses and now
he's like acting like he's our best
friend i forgot what that dude's name is
john
you know who it is man you know you know
exactly yeah he hung out with pat
i kind of feel like more bullies
should realize what they did back he's
gonna dig out the year maybe they do
he's gonna dig out the yearbook he's
gonna dig out the yearbook you'll
remember as soon as you see him you'll
go that [ __ ] right there yeah
yeah you'll you'll recognize him
you got a yearbook i don't have a
yearbook from trenton
i don't even think i was in a yearbook
from trenton i have yearbook somewhere
but i don't know where they are
what did i do with them when we moved
they were in the attic i think yeah so
it went wherever all the stuff from the
attic went to
i'm not i enjoyed high school but
it wasn't really i was only friends with
a handful of people and the handful of
people i was friends with i'm still
friends with at least on facebook and
stuff
so
i don't really feel the need to like
keep up with all the other [ __ ]
so i don't give a [ __ ] about any of them
yeah most of them are dicks he's digging
he's digging out he's digging out the
yearbook trying to figure it out
josh where's roshan
john
[Music]
i kind of looking back on him you know
even back in the day i kind of felt bad
for him because he had turned so many
people against him
by being a [ __ ] thug and the
[ __ ] was huge he was
for high school he was huge i probably
see him now they gotta beat that bitch's
ass but back in the day you know what i
mean [ __ ]
you know weigh anything you know nobody
really weighs but we had so few monsters
in high school though big [ __ ] roid
rage and mother john chris
christie yeah yeah john christophe
crystal that's exactly it that's exactly
it john christophe that's right
that what's he look like
because i remember him being just this
[ __ ] monster
like a [ __ ] thug like a [ __ ] big
dude he probably looks like a little kid
now when you look at him now john
cousteau
yeah
that's exactly what i'm talking about
you nailed it
haven't [ __ ] said that dude's name in
forever yeah i remember way more stuff
from high school yeah that [ __ ]
was a serious dick for a couple of years
and then all of a sudden he tried to be
the coolest [ __ ] ever
and uh he was friendly
hey i was a jerk which he said that to
be fair he said that 95 of people never
do that he came up so good for him he
came up to me
and uh to me and mike and he goes look
i used to be a bully i used to bully you
guys and [ __ ] and he goes that's not
the way to go [ __ ] you guys are okay
man it was me that's what he said
that's awesome that's what he said i
wish more people would do that he said
it was me it's not you guys it was me
seriously ninety-nine percent of people
ninety-nine ninety-nine percent of
people will never do that every time we
saw him i don't know if he got help or
whatever every time we saw her like
what's up man what's up nate and then he
was cool after that
dude that's cool because he goes he's
there he can learn he's like everybody
hates me that's what he said everybody
hates me because i'm not a bad person
see but i kind of feel like
and this is what kind of makes me sad
about the human race is that 95 of the
time maybe not 91
but a lot of the time i kind of feel
like somebody like that even at that age
they would jump to the conclusion not
that hey i should look at my life
choices yeah and maybe like maybe
there's something wrong with me maybe i
should like work on me
which is what you should do
but i kind of feel like 90 95 of people
will be like everybody's [ __ ] so i'm
going to become an even bigger [ __ ]
yeah like to counteract because i kind
of feel like that's
the path that a lot of people think
unfortunately listen to what grantor
says he goes last i heard he was
managing the peppermint rhino in vegas a
strip bar
okay okay cool cool nice
hanging out rhino that's a great name
yeah the peppermint rhino
maybe i have to look him up john
cousteau telling me he's that i remember
[ __ ] i remember how he changed you
should look him up yeah because like i
said i i kind of feel like [ __ ] like
that yeah that should be rewarded
because most people don't do that right
most people don't have that level of
insight
to be like hey especially at that age
hey
yeah i was a piece of [ __ ]
and have the balls enough
to go to people that they had wronged
and say hey i was a piece of [ __ ] i'm
sorry about that yeah i'm changing it
i'm going to say it's a piece of [ __ ]
well no i'm just saying yes
i'm just saying like but back in those
days
i mean that's kind of a big deal yeah
that's kind of a big deal and i kind of
feel like enough people don't do that
don't do well
grandpa's gonna test he was there
um
that era
and um trenton high school was a good
high school it was a very good high
school
and uh michigan
boring state this is to be honest man
it's a boring state well i don't think
anyone's going to argue
about that
but it's not an unimportant state it had
[ __ ] happen in there with the car
industry [ __ ] you know they had a
[ __ ]
beverly hills cop was partially [ __ ]
set in the detroit area it was uh fun
good-looking people good-looking girls
um it is the siberia of america is the
tanko grad of america where they make
all the tanks and [ __ ] in russia it's
like that kind of like the siberia of
america
but yeah i always thought of trenton
high
when it came to my experiences uh in the
united states and i've had experiences
[ __ ] in california and
um mississippi michigan and even in
brazil and in other countries and stuff
with uh because i went to high school in
brazil also
michigan was kind of like a good
median
kind of like the center line of what
america was back in those era back in
that era
and it was a good place um it had good
people
and a good cross section of of american
humanity at that time
i looked back at michigan
uh with a good memories
michigan is the bob seger of countries
of states it is the bob seger of
american states that's kind of what it's
like
are you really sure you want to like
yeah yeah
it is the bob seger of american states
but i i still
good place to grow up
kind of like uh something out of uh back
to the future if you're a foreigner and
you see the back to the future trilogy
that's the way america that's the way
michigan was and uh well a lot of places
were a lot of places like that it was
meant to be kind of generic but it was
like that
i mean even places here in florida are
like that yeah to be honest yeah and it
were back then yeah
that was that that's why so many people
resonated with that movie was because
yeah it was you could relate to it
wherever you were right
if you weren't in a place that was like
super
one thing or the other yeah if you were
just in suburbia suburbia is kind of the
scene yeah everywhere
i would say uh if anything stuck out of
my mind for my time in michigan
was um
the the time of life i was having it was
my [ __ ] teens and 20s cute girls cute
girls like michigan had cute girls
i don't know if it's still like that but
it did back then
did they have big hair
big hair and they were [ __ ] um goth
and industrial and they had all that
[ __ ] you could go to [ __ ] you could
go you could go to uh industry you could
go to st andrews hall you could go to
city club uh yeah cute girls
i mean everywhere has well i don't know
if i'd say everywhere but mostly
everywhere
has something to
uh you know something to
that that people could like
uh
you know latch onto you know what i'm
saying michigan was um
because of the uh
uh the ethnic makeup
very polished they called them polox
pullout girls
um
and um
uh uh [ __ ]
what else was it grampus polish girls
looks like a norwegian polish but yeah
no norris very very scandinavian
a lot of swedish people very nordic
uh type state
it's because it's cold up there so
that's that's where a lot of uh
nordic eastern european czechoslovakian
slovak type people moved to michigan
back in the day they're like hey and
african people a lot of black people
after the civil war moved up there like
hey we know this uh climate yeah
we're into this
bundy data says bottom line not romantic
and women want romance
i'm not sure if that's true or i'm not
really sure how men are defining romance
as opposed to how women define romance
is that maybe where the
where the uh
where the [ __ ] is
coming apart
i'm not really sure
grandpa says polish italian and arabic
yeah now be arabic especially around
dearborn
yeah
although i think [ __ ] when i was
there dearborn was ta and hi if dearborn
was totally insular you know nobody came
out of there they just went in there
people went in there they didn't come
out
it's not like they're marrying other
people i don't know if it's changed but
uh back in those days they didn't even
there was a lot of iraqis
when uh when we were there too
you know what's interesting though i
kind of feel like people
talk about like uh you know like
immigrants in the middle east like from
nowadays but
when i was a kid
growing up in [ __ ] redneck ass
daytona beach
um
we knew like a lot of kids from like
iran and stuff like that yeah well there
was always yeah always
in high school when i was there in
michigan there was a lot of them from
when i was thinking lebanon yeah like
elementary school or like so it's been
going on for like ages
and honestly like nobody made that big
of a deal about it
i mean they did but not really
the thing is though as i go if i could
you probably have to go back and look
like my friend mike he was working in
all these gas stations and working for
uh guys that were lebanese
the chances are they're probably not in
michigan anymore they probably went back
to lebanon uh
i think a lot of them come they stay for
a while then they go back
uh
so
i guess it's immigration it's just that
it's just not
it's not like they're settling here
though you know what i mean well they
might come here for a while there's like
yeah
yeah this is the thing
americans are prejudiced they think that
other foreigners want to come here to
live here and stay here forever and
become americans and that's not what
happens
a lot of mexicans will move here a lot
of central and south americans will move
here
be here for a certain period of time and
god [ __ ] this and then they don't
they go back home they don't like well
that happens like a lot of immigrants
like you know [ __ ]
we we had a friend that [ __ ] married
a friend of ours and he was from
columbia and he was here for only about
a year and so he's like oh [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this angel he went back he went
back home i don't like it
so you know what i mean just because you
come here doesn't mean you're gonna stay
here
well i was married to a brit and we
lived here for a long time and after
time he was just like yeah [ __ ] this
yeah this isn't the 1970s or the 80s
other countries [ __ ] are kind of
caught up with the united states
you don't have to be in the united
states to have a good time you can have
a good time anywhere now
well and honestly like some people like
other countries better yeah because they
have other things i could go back to
brazil today and have a [ __ ] great
time well honestly um if you told me
today that i was like i had to move to
the uk because like i said i'm
i wouldn't be bothered
i would i wouldn't be bothered i i
actually can't find anywhere i quite
liked the uk when i was there yeah
if somebody told me i had to move there
i i would not be bothered okay so how
long have you been streaming jen three
hours all right it's about time shout
out
this time
um and i'll make it some deep
okay wait a minute let me make sure
okay i think we've like answered all the
questions yeah right yeah
yeah
i'm good to go all right what are you
gonna make uh we'll see when i get down
there oh here i got stuff down there all
right uh okay so
sunday
we'll be back on the matinee show do you
want to do like a full whole
full-fledged review on the north band
yeah we'll do a full-fledged review
because i know you're like dying to like
talk hold on uh graham sim uh send me a
uh send me a message on messenger too so
i can i can get you on messenger he sent
me
his phone number so we can talk but
on facebook but um okay yeah let me see
let me see you guys should talk he might
be on that
okay yeah i got you i got it okay i got
you okay i got you so you guys you guys
hook up but yes we'll be back sunday
probably talk about the north man um
you know because we saw it yesterday and
it was awesome
so
i mean tom like talked about a lot but
we'll talk about it more on sunday
hopefully a more focused conversation
so
you guys have a good
friday evening
and saturday
and we will see you guys again thank you
everybody
everybody for like super chats and all
that kind of stuff and we will see you
again on sunday evening
thanks for hanging out with us
and
bye